at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
oock it's like progress
hey everybody what's talk [__] before
they we're always like in the middle of
a conversation like when I starting the
thing
yeah this is going to be a good show
this case holy crap you guys okay so
it's two books yeah I had never heard of
this and I kind of feel like a lot of
people haven't heard of this and you
know I'm I'm a true crime junkie you
guys
know um but I had never heard of this
and I think even somebody commented on
Monday night's show when I said what the
show was about they were like man I'm
from Minnesota where this happened and I
never even heard of this so it's like so
i' never heard of it and it actually um
our listener mut sent us two books about
it uh both of which I actually did have
time to read um you know I actually this
one this longer one I just finished like
today um cuz I was kind of taking notes
like the whole time but I did read both
of these holy [__] this story is crazy
and it's just like not even I mean the
murders are terrible and bad enough and
everything like but all the [__] that
happened after the murders is also kind
of insane so I'm actually kind of
surprised that um that this isn't better
known I did look there were a couple of
other YouTube like there was a
documentary about it actually there was
one documentary about on YouTube that I
thought was about the murders but it
wasn't it was just about the Mansion
like the history of the Mansion which is
also interesting um there I think there
were like two other documentaries like
kind of about the murders but even like
some of the big True Crime podcasters
had not covered this one one so I would
really like to thank mut for sending me
these books cuz I don't think I ever
would have found this case on my own and
this case was [__] bad [__] this is
bad [__] yeah great she told me a little
bit of it yeah I told her a little bit
of it last night but like all of the
details and I can't cover everything
obviously that was in this book but I
was like reading this book going no
[__] way oh my God this is like so
this is crazy I'm like surprised more
people don't know about it but uh yeah
Zach said that Mansion is my dream it's
gorgeous and I saw like um there was a
YouTube video of a guy who was just like
touring it like inside cuz you can tour
it it's a tourist attraction kind of one
of the biggest tourist attractions it's
in duth Minnesota um and it has 39 rooms
and it's gorgeous inside it's gorgeous
here's the thing like I looked on the
website because a lot of people say cuz
there's like hauntings and [__] too
although I didn't go too much into that
I did watch a video that was about
hauntings but it wasn't really all that
interesting it's just like people were
saying like oh I heard screams coming
from outside the house and I'm just like
yeah whoop you do it it's not that big a
deal um the the real [__] that happened
around the house is a lot more
interesting than like the Paranormal
[__] so a lot of people said that it's
like oh you can tour the house obviously
but um the tour guides are under strict
orders like not to talk about the
murders that is apparently not quite the
case um I don't think that they talk
about it as part of their regular tour
guide Spiel but if you ask them about it
they will tell you like truthfully what
happened they don't hide it or anything
like that and the justification that
they gave on their website was that well
you know yeah a lot of people interested
in murders and stuff but that was one
night this house has had like a lot of
history that's interesting besides that
and we so we don't want to focus so much
on that you know we want to cover all
the other stuff too if you ask us about
it we'll talk about it but other than
that they don't so it's so that's kind
of what it is so before we like just as
a broad
outline what happened with this was that
this happened back in like I said it's
in duu Minnesota it's a very famous
house in that area like I said that you
can tour and stuff and in
1977 two women were murdered in the
house one of the woman one of the women
was Elizabeth conden who at the time was
the owner of the house she had inherited
it from her father and she was like
super super wealthy she was like an ays
at this point she was fairly elderly she
had had a stroke and was kind of
bedridden um she was actually smothered
to death with a
pillow also murdered was her nurse who I
believe is in her 40s who was beaten to
death in the head with a brass
Candlestick now now who they thought did
this and we'll get into all the
particulars like in a bit but who they
thought did this was the husband of one
of Elizabeth Conan's adopted daughters
who may be legit a crazy person I mean
she's not a crazy person but I think
that she has some
real issues and is possibly allegedly
maybe a serial killer
um just depending she was never
convicted of that she was convicted of
some other things but there are a lot of
suspicions floating around about her um
as far as I know she is still alive uh I
think she would be about 91 years old at
this point she was in prison for a time
but she got out quite a while ago I
believe she lives in Tucson
Arizona um but yeah I think she's still
walking around but she's 91 I don't
think she's going to hurt anybody now
but you know
possibly a serial killer for sure an
arsonist that's she was convicted of
that but this woman I think I said that
when I was telling Tom about the book
last night I just kind of went like that
and I was just like this [__] woman I
was just and she got away with so much
[__] if she did like a quarter of the
stuff that they suspect that she did but
probably couldn't prove like I said
she's legit a serial killer and she's
kind of one of those women
that for whatever reason is real good at
manipulating people into doing [__] she
wants even though she's not like super
hot or nothing like that but she's just
like really good at doing that and she's
also one of those people that's
real she's just always got a scam going
she gets she's always got a scam going
and then when somebody calls her out on
it she like plays a victim like I don't
know why you're picking on me like I
have all of these health problems and
I'm a wonderful person and I do this
that and the other thing like I've known
kind of people like that in my life so I
kind of know what they're getting at
with that but I don't know this [__]
[__] is just crazy it's crazy um Zach
says I love mock tutor houses I believe
it's jacoban but um I'm not actually
sure that's what it was built to to look
like you know what I mean because I
think the reason it's called Glenn Sheen
was because the man who bought it who
was like an he was like an iron
magnate um and he wanted it to look like
the English country houses like I said
the from the jacoban era and they called
it Glenn because it was like in all of
these um woods and stuff and then they
the sheen was from the some English
Village that supposedly his ancestors
had come from or something like that so
that's why they called the house that
you know what I mean but like I said I'm
not even going to be able to scratch the
surface of all the crazy [__] that this
woman did but I I did like take a lot of
notes so hopefully this I don't think
the show will be five hours long I know
I always kind of say that but it's it's
a lot it's a
lot so I don't know so like I said so I
gave like a little bit do we have
anything that we need to talk about
before um no not that I not that I know
like anything that we kind of need to
cover before I we might be able to roll
it is there's nothing um nothing hanger
or nothing uh we need to announce no new
patreons or anything like that I don't
think no I would normally have written
that down all right yeah then yeah Danny
said it was Colonel Mustard with the
Candlestick yeah it's it is very clu
likee this murder um
except I was saying a time I was like um
this
murder I mean they were pretty sure they
knew who did it but it's technically
unsolved because the person who was
convicted of doing it the conviction was
overturned like a few years later and
then they never convicted anyone else of
it so technically it's unsolved but
everyone's pretty sure that they know
who did it although it's possible that
that wasn't what happened but unlikely
in my op I was just remind you that last
week was almost five hours I know yeah I
try to like but here's the thing I get
so and particularly with this case cuz I
had a whole book about it yeah and it's
just kind of like so I had a bunch of
notes written beforehand like that I got
just from various other sources and then
when I started reading the book I was
like oh that's good I got to put that in
oh that's good too I got to put that in
there too I'll tell you one thing long
videos they were really helping me out
that [__] trip to Mississippi and
well there you go was uh I was driving
that rented H uh that rented Toyota and
I listened to Dam Wang Wang the whole
way yeah and I was looking for his like
four and six hour show yeah it's really
good it's just like it kills a lot of
time quickly if you're working or you're
traveling yeah one long one [__]
takes a yeah what I do a lot like if I'm
working on like if I get a really big
graphic design project that I know is
going to take hours and hours like I'll
usually put on like six hours of scary
stories you know what I mean like from B
Buster or Mr nightmare or something like
that you don't get as many commercial
interruptions you have to choose another
one you just let it ride yeah you just
kind of like you don't have to worry
about it going to and finding another
video and stuff so you can just kind of
listen to it in the background like yeah
I do that a lot too yeah Wang's come out
with big compilations now he's posted
yeah those are great actually great yeah
although there's some on there that I
can't watch because they're too gross
because they're too gross talking about
setting cats on fire and catching dudes
oh yeah well the one we started watching
like that was like the first case and we
were both like nope yeah I don't like to
hear about animal Cru no I don't I could
handle human human on Cru I know that's
[__] up but it's like yeah you can I
can hear about [__] being done to humans
all day long not necessarily innocent
humans that kind of is [__] up too but
at least the human knows what's
happening yeah anytime like they start
talking about like people doing [__] to
animals I had a hard time watching that
documentary don't [__] with cats because
I did watch it but I was just kind of
like oh God I hope they don't [__]
show the [__] cuz I'm not going to I
don't that rattling around in my brain
no yeah animals don't know why they're
being killed they don't they don't know
what they've done wrong well it's like
it's like doing it to a baby yeah it's
like doing it to a baby yeah which is
you know what I mean it's like Jesus
Christ at least a human knows that
they've fallen into the hands of a
psychopath and it's not [__] normal
what's happening right you know I mean
which helps him [__] understand
what's happening this dude's crazy yeah
but yeah I mean Wang will do like whole
shows about like you know the famous you
know [__] jars and stuff like that and
I'm just like no thanks that's pretty
nasty I like no story
I can't watch it without gagging I think
I think some of it was fake well I'm
sure it was I think those dud because
that was dudes that was just [__]
dudes on the internet trying to gross
each other out it'd be easy for those
guys to fake that yeah it would be easy
to fake it but still just thinking about
it yeah even if it is fake even just
thinking about if it was real like makes
me want to throw so so I have a hard
time watch that's why they did it I know
well it worked good job yeah 14-year-old
basement dwellers yeah 14y old boys
trying to gross each other
you made me kind of want to throw up
yeah so yeah there's
that um yeah Danny says long shows are
the best though yeah I mean as long as I
don't get like so inebriated that I lose
track of what I'm doing yeah we're at
the end of and we're not quite sure what
we're talking about well like I said the
Sidetrack show it doesn't matter as much
yeah you know what I mean because we're
just talking about [__] anyway yeah
but uh these ones I kind of like to keep
a little bit uh
coherent but yeah so um so this house
here uh was originally built by like I
said um his name was uh
Chester
conden who was a big mining magnate now
the interesting thing was that he was
kind of like I I know there's kind of a
thing that like in Americana that it's
just oh these Rags to Riches stories a
lot of those are kind of [__] like
because I kind of feel like a lot of the
people that make a [__] ton of money
they came from families that already had
[__] tons of money but you do kind of
hear the occasional r to Rich's story
and Chester conden seems to have been
one of those where he came from kind of
a workingclass family um he was a little
bit older like I think he was in his 40s
and then he just so happened to come
across this you know he he invested in
iron in a place where nobody else
thought to invest in it blah blah and he
ended up getting super super super
wealthy I mean that's a simplification
but that's basically what happened so
he's the one that ended up building this
house Glen Sheen like I said it's 30 39
room Mansion it's on the shores of Lake
Superior and it's beautiful as you can
see from the pictures and like I said
you can still tour it uh nowadays you
going to show the pictures no I don't
have pictures well there's pictures all
over Google I don't need I don't need to
be doing that all right you know what I
mean sometimes I'll get if there's like
a particular video or something I'm
talking about I will but it's like
normally I'm just kind of like I don't
want this to turn into a slideshow again
you know what I mean um so yeah now so
here's the thing so Chester had a bunch
of kids now his youngest daughter whose
name was Elizabeth now she was the woman
that would eventually sadly uh end up
getting murdered in 1977 but that was
his youngest daughter now kind of
unusual for the time cuz I believe this
was around the 1930s that she did this
she never married um apparently and by
all accounts I have never heard and I
did quite a bit of research about this I
have never heard anybody say single bad
word about this woman she was like an
angel on Earth they said she was just
like the best [__] person it's like
even when she had all this money she
never flaunted it she gave to charity
like all this money to Charity she was
super generous and it's like and she was
just like a really really nice like a
good person but for whatever reason she
just didn't really wasn't into the whole
marriage thing um I Heard a story that
when she was younger she had a Suitor
that asked for her hand in marriage and
she was just kind she was nice about it
but she was just kind of like nah not
really my thing or whatever and he was
cool about it too which is good um but
he was
so D I guess he was so into her that
it's like he took the ring threw it in
the lake or something like that and he
never married like the whole his whole
entire life he never married anybody
else cuz I guess he was just like so
hung up on her so that should tell you
something [__] all that yeah [__] all
that yeah but yeah she never
married the weird thing about it though
was that in the 1930s which was very
unusual she want decided she wanted
children but didn't want the whole
husband
situation so she actually adopted a
daughter in
1932 and then later in 1935 she adopted
another one so I guess if you have a lot
of money they'll let you do it CU like I
said very unusual in 19 particularly
1930s to let a single mother well it's
even unusual nowadays they usually like
to have you know at least somebody that
has like enough money that they know can
take care of the kids you know what I
mean if you're single got money that's
what I mean so I guess that's that's
probably yeah so that's probably what
the case was even back in the 1930s if
you had as much money as she had cuz she
was you know an ays then you could kind
of do what you wanted so she did end up
eventually adopting two daughters now it
was the one that she got in 1932 that's
going to be a source of a lot of the
problems so that one uh was actually
born her original name was Jack
Barnes now she was born in July of 1932
um to I guess an unwed mother in North
Carolina now so Elizabeth goes and
adopts
her
and changed her name to margerie so now
her name is margerie conden like I said
this is the woman that will be the
source of a lot of the problems 1935
three years later she adopted another
daughter named Jennifer
now both of the girls were brought up at
Glenn Sheen and had obviously the best
of everything this was an extremely
extremely wealthy
family um you know they had horses they
had pretty much like whatever they
wanted you know what I
mean uh they went to private schools
boarding schools all that kind of stuff
rich people [__] you know what I mean
the thing about margerie though and a
lot of people said this even from when
she was
younger was that margorie kind of had
some problems like she was a little bit
troubled I guess when she was as she was
getting older people started like
noticing
stuff now it seemed
like it was probably the case that she
might have needed some discipline and
some structure in her life um but I
don't think
Elizabeth really knew what to do with
her other than just giving her whatever
she wanted which is not great for this
type of person but on the other hand I
think
margorie considering what we will know
about her as the show goes on I think
she probably has like a lot of mental
health issues that I don't know if
parenting would have fixed you know what
I'm
saying now they did say that Marjorie
was quite
introverted um a little bit I don't know
if I'd go so as far as to say antisocial
but she wasn't real gregarious or
outgoing or anything like that uh she
was quite spoiled and um you know cuz
she was used to getting what she wanted
she was very bossy uh they called her
that
too um and later on like she was having
such
problems that at some point Elizabeth
her mother didn't really know what to do
with her and was advised to send her to
like a psychiatrist you know what I mean
so it must have been pretty
egregious so when she was 16 um they
sent her to this place uh called the men
menager clinic in Topeka Kansas for like
troubled
adolescents at this point she was
reportedly diagnosed as a quote unquote
sociopath remember that for later
because that will definitely come into
play so they noticed that even back then
so this would have been what the 1940s
or early 1950s um they recognized that
there was something the matter with her
like even when she was a
teenager um so there was that now one of
the things that stood out to me that was
in the book um of something that she did
one like I said she was real spoiled so
she decided that she really wanted a
horse like a lot of girls do she's a
horse girl and Tom says horse girls are
crazy they're [__] crazy worked in
the industry that is true in this case
they got nice they're nice they're nice
but you got there's always a streak of
crazy in horse
girls especially if they've been in this
industry for a long time they start
getting in their 20s and 30s [__] are
crazy yeah yeah well this [__] was for
sure crazy I don't think it had anything
to do with horses but yeah so she she
very badly wanted a horse so her mom who
was always I like I said her mom was not
one of those who's like oh I'm buying
her love or anything like that she was
just kind of like she had wanted
children really badly um she wasn't
married and she's just like she adopted
them so she appreciated them so she
wanted to give them everything I think
it was kind of more of that kind of
situation so margerie really wanted a
horse so her mom bought her a horse as
you do and after a while margorie didn't
really give a [__] about the horse
anymore like she didn't really want to
take care of her she's just like care of
it or whatever I think it was a male
horse actually but um she's like yeah
[__] it whatever so at this point
Elizabeth is like well you know we could
sell the horse to someone who if you
don't really want to take care of him
anymore you don't want to ride him
anymore then we'll sell him to somebody
who will take care of him and stuff like
that not too long after Elizabeth made
this
decision Apparently one of the stable
hands or somebody that worked on the
estate or something walked into the
stable and saw Marjorie in there feeding
hay to the horse and they thought it was
a little bit unusual cuz she like I said
she didn't really like bother with the
horse anymore so the stable hand was
like well I wonder what the [__] is
going on with that and then he said that
she acted like super Shifty like she
turned around like oh [__] like she
wasn't supposed to be in there and she
dropped some [__] and ran out and they
said when he looked in the the handful
of hay that she had there was a bunch of
pills in there she trying to kill the
horse so she was trying to poison the
horse because she didn't want anyone
else to have it if she couldn't that's
what they thought they did save the
horse that the horse was fine and he got
sold to somebody else so it was okay I
was worried about that I'm like what
happened to the horse he was fine she
probably had no idea what she was doing
it would take a lot to kill a horse with
you get that was human medicine I yeah
probably I don't know exactly what the
pills were and I think she was a
teenager at this point so I think her
only thought was oh well they're going
to sell the horse if nobody else can
have it if I can't have it even though
she wasn't willing to take care of it so
you can kind of see the sort of
mentality we're dealing with here yeah
now the interesting thing about Marjorie
and her sister
Jennifer um they weren't particularly
close when they were growing up Marjorie
um always said that she never felt as
though she belonged in the family I mean
they were both adopted but the thing
about it was that margorie like I said
was very introverted and she would just
like kind of hole up in a room and read
and like you know the servants never saw
her and she wasn't real outgoing or
anything like that like I said while
Jennifer was actually a lot more
outgoing and she was real friendly and
you know and everybody in the house just
loved her to death also Jennifer looked
a lot more like their mother like she
was real fair and have blonde hair and
stuff whereas margorie was kind of more
darkhaired and she had like a little bit
of an olive skin kind of thing so she
kind of felt like an outcast I guess um
so there was kind of a lot of stress and
tension in the household because of
that so um you know just to please their
mothers they would kind of you know they
both were bridesmaids at each other's
weddings but you know that like I said
they didn't really get along and I'll
kind of get a little bit more into that
later on some bad [__] happens um but
Jennifer eventually married and moved
with her husband to
Wisconsin now in the early 1950s when
Marjorie had you know was had grown up a
little bit she moved to St Louis
Missouri and ended up marrying this guy
named dick ly which dick ly that sounds
like it's like a porn name it sounds
like a porn name it does yeah I mean his
real name was Richard ly was doesn't
sound as much like a porn name but for
sure dick ly everybody called him dick
so he was an insurance
executive now these two would be married
for about 20 years and would eventually
have seven [__] children they had
seven
children now dick ly I'm just going to
say his whole name like that because
it's so amusing um he got transferred to
Minnesota so they moved to Minneapolis
and then ended up moving to this
neighborhood I think called St Louis
Park or something like that now the
neighbors at that point they said that
Marjorie was very what they called
industrious they said she always had a
project going like she was always
spending all this money to beautify
their houses and stuff like that like I
said this is kind of it it'll all come
into play like later
on um also one of her other neighbors
said that her children always looked
Immaculate like they always had like
super fancy like expensive designer
clothes on never had a hair out of place
um you know everything was tired
impressed and everything like that said
she loved to throw parties um and it was
always like super formal like people
would come over and she'd have this
really fancy like three four course meal
or whatever like she had all the silver
and the China and all that kind of crap
um and it was just
very according to Dick the husband um I
don't know if he knew that margorie was
essentially an ays the thing about it
was that when Elizabeth eleth conden who
was the last daughter surviving daughter
of Chester conden who was the guy that
had built glennen Mansion um she was the
last one so when she died all of the all
of the heirs like all of her children
would get um a bunch of money like there
was a whole bunch of trusts like set up
for all of them and they had even set up
trusts for for both the adopted girls
and like a bunch of um Elizabeth's other
you know relations and all of their kids
and families like I said this was a very
wealthy
family so I'm not sure if dick knew that
his wife was an ays who was in line to
but she certainly lived like she was one
and she kind of wanted everybody to know
that she came from this big cuz she was
raised in a mansion with servants and
[__] and had horses and everything so
she was kind of like used to living that
way I
guess so
I also heard and this might have been a
little bit later but this was another
thing that I read in the book like a lot
of people that knew her they said well
she was kind of um loud and kind of like
pushy and abrasive and stuff like that
but she was like super super generous
she would like buy people like really
expensive [__] um you know make gifts
for them and stuff like that so a lot of
she did have a lot of friends like a lot
of people thought she was really nice so
like when [__] happened later like about
the murders and everything people were
shocked however one of her friends did
say that being friends with her was like
a roller coaster because they were like
one day she would be like the most
generous awesome nicest person ever and
she would just give you the shirt off
her back and she would do anything for
you um and then the next day like if she
did if you did something that she
thought was against her like she would
be like super vindictive and she would
just like so she was kind of like that
you know what I mean I kind of feel like
it was what do they call that bipolar
yeah like yeah it might have been
something like that um but I was
thinking of something like not
narcissistic personality disorder but
antisocial personality disorder I can't
even remember what it is but it's I kind
of felt like it was something like that
or it might have been bipolar there's a
bunch of different ones and they all
kind of read like fortune cookies to me
I go yeah I kind of see that in certain
people I see some of that in myself it's
hard to say know the psychology this
well the thing about it though is that
to have to be diagnosed as that it's
like there's a long list and usually
have to have like most of the [__] on
that list cuz everybody has one or two
things on the list you know what I mean
they're just describing
[__] pretty much yeah different
kinds of [__] different yeah
different flavors of [__] yeah
[__] [__] and this chick I don't
know if [__] is the right
term um I'm I'm kind of hard I've known
people like this but I'm kind of
hardpressed to put my finger on like a
word like a single word that I would use
to describe her like I said we'll get
more into it maybe you can think of
something but yeah so she was
clearly
very um concerned about her image she
wanted everybody to know that she one
had a lot of money and had all this
refinement and everything and two was
like a super cool person see that's what
I mean I don't know entirely if she
actually was like if there was some part
of her that was like a really cool
generous person that was like oh yeah
I'll give you know my friend this like
car or whatever or if she was just doing
that so everyone would think she was
awesome I think I suspect it was the
second thing because I think she was
like like they diagnosed her as I think
she was a little bit sociopathic so I
think everything that she did was in
service to her own image this R is
working out I'm enjoying rum me and been
[__] with the rum past couple yeah I
got a rum and coke yeah I got rum and
fruit that I grew out in the backyard
out of the garden out of the G like I
said that's some organic farmed table
[__] right there and I spiked it with a
little bit of lemon juice that I grew on
the lemon tree out there that's right
making food [__] making making the
food that I make the food out
of like I said we didn't make the rum
although if we grow some sugar cane I
guess we could probably do that that
sounds kind of hard but yeah we could
probably got get still yeah we haven't
we haven't got to that we haven't got to
that point yet you got to buy a lot of
sugar yeah it is lot of things that you
need yeah it's not
free I'm not sure you
could you could probably make it in bulk
cheaper than you can buy it but it's
probably a situation kind of like ice
cream you cannot save money make ice
cream you I mean it's cost more to make
the ice cream than it's good if you make
it cuz we used to make it when I was a
kid like cuz we had like the little ice
cream maker thing requires a lot of
cream and a lot of eggs aot you can buy
it's not really worth it it's not worth
the money unless you probably were to
buy it all in bulk and make a [__] ton
of it but you probably have to make 50
gallons of it cuz crap man you can just
you can go buy we got some Publix ice
cream the other day I think it was like
two gallons for $9 or something like
that and that shit's delicious no it was
a gallon for $9 two half things oh two
half gallons okay yeah Publix ice cream
is [__] great it's almost as good
it's as good as Bluebell I think it is
yeah yeah I got some Blue Bell on in
Mississippi Bluebell [__] strawberry
men and Sh was I forgot how good that
was I haven't had Blue Bell in a while
but you know
we'll get we'll get back to that we got
back to show oh actually or when you go
get another drink like put some more ice
in my [__] fin [__] all like please cuz
it all
melted so uh so
yeah and but like I said a lot of the
friends so like this one woman who was a
neighbor of theirs like after they moved
cuz they moved around Minnesota for a
little while and um some of the houses
they had were like large like I said
they were trying to put on a good face
like look how much money I have and
everything like that
now one of the ladies that was the a
neighbor of theirs said yeah man like
Marjorie was so cool and it's like she
um like the lady that had once lived in
their old house like she was pregnant
it's just like man she gave us all these
maternity clothes and she brought when I
was in the hospital giving birth she
brought me like all these strawberries
and she brought me all this stuff
however this same woman also said she
was like a compulsive liar which is
another thing that a lot of people said
about her so this she's kind of a weird
woman so her husband dick was still
working at this point I think he kind of
stopped working later on because she was
like oh I got all this money so don't
worry about it um but he did have an
office however
margerie um who claimed later on that
she's like well I really never learned
to handle money because when she grew up
she just always had whatever she wanted
which I guess that's kind of legit but
she just spent money like it was nothing
like she would just go and shop she
would just spend thousands and thousands
and thousands and thousands of dollars
like um on [__] for her kids on [__] for
the Neighbors on [__] for the house she
would just spend it like without
worrying about it now for a long time
dick her husband didn't know about any
of this but then he starts getting bills
like because I guess they had joint
accounts right so he's like so I'm
getting he's getting all these bills
he's like what the [__] are these for I
didn't spend $54,000 on whatever it was
and everything like that he's like what
the [__] is happening and then would
always kind of like come up with some
kind of story you know what I mean what
ended up happening was that dick the
husband would end up asking Elizabeth
his mother-in-law for money like to
cover the bills cuz he's like we're
going to get like foreclosed on or
whatever because she's spending
thousands like she just she spent money
like she had unlimited money and they
didn't have unlimited money she thought
she did she thought she had unlimited
money it wasn't her money like she had
the thing about it was she had a trust
like from her family but it gave her
like a stipend like a monthly I don't
even remember how much it was I mean it
was a lot but was compulsive Shoppers
like yeah she just seemed like she just
spent and spent and spent and she just
like wasn't even used to have this on
this [__] television shopping channel
what's it called QVC yeah and it was
just these people all day long selling
you these items and people buying it it
was back before the internet just
telephone I mean I'm pretty sure that
shit's still on it's probably still on I
think it's still on and evidently like
dat it came out that overwhelmingly who
was buying that was [__] compulsive
Shoppers and they were broke older women
single in trailer homes trailer parks
and then they end up being like hoarders
and they're hoarding yeah they're
because we see that a lot if you watch
hoarders yeah like oh my God the women
that are on there and like I said I
always say this because I feel like the
first few seasons of Hoarders I think
they gave like a skewed perception
because it was almost all women hoarders
it's are more likely to be men but they
hoard in a slight different way like for
slightly different reasons but the women
that they had on there were oh they were
all about the QVC either that or they
were real into thrift stores yeah
because if you go to the thrift store
and you're like hey this is only a
dollar hey that's only a dollar and then
suddenly you spent like $500 you know
what I mean yeah and then they have it
in a bag and then they throw it in a
corner and they never and they never
even open it yeah and and that's that
QVC [__] was doing that which is crazy
well yeah cuz some of them ordered [__]
from K they never even opened the box
box they just because the high that got
was from buying the [__] they don't
really give a [__] they talk to the
salesperson over the phone
yeah yeah yeah they interact CU there's
obviously a lot of emotional issues that
they're dealing with by the shopping
yeah and they're buying just costume
jewelry and [__] little statues yeah
[__] that they and like I said a lot of
times they never even take cred they
never even take it out of the box yeah
they don't have the money they just got
credit cards and I'm sitting there
thinking how the [__] do these people
get all of this credit like they won't
give me any more credit that's for sure
and I don't do that [__] you got all
love credit cards that are [__] maxed
out well I know that but it's like they
probably do too you pay it though at
least but I do pay them yeah that's what
I mean I do pay them all we need to get
that [__] paid down well I know but I'm
just saying give Jen a Super Chat pay
credit so I can pay my credit
card I have like I get credit cards I
got my credit's great well yeah well you
didn't even start married you find out I
married you probably F my credit far as
I know no I won't you don't think so
it'll be all right yeah I got I got a
[__] I got a [__] City group for
for for ref credit card offer saying
you're pre-approved for this [__]
[__] just call us yeah but I get
those too yeah and like if you do call
them they're like no yeah but I've seen
my credit rating is good well yeah they
probably give it to you they wouldn't
give it to me my [__] is between used to
be excellent now I'm just very good but
the thing about it is that yeah like I
said I know that you were kind of like
scared about that but I'm just kind of
like but I do pay the bills I'm not late
on them or anything like that so you
know what I mean so you just got to get
a windfall we F can pay some of that
[__] down yeah I would like like to kind
of like pay and honestly like compared
to some other people I know it's not
really that bad I mean I don't have that
much credit card de like I was with her
when she spent all legit well Mo and the
thing abouto well and the thing about it
is that 90% of it was Necessities I
needed it because it's like oh I lost a
job and it's like I had to buy groceries
or gas or something like that it just
all and it all added up you know what I
mean a lot of it and about a 3mon period
a lot of it occurred like after my
divorce yeah it was about a 3mon period
you know what I mean cuz I had to buy sh
for my apartment and I bu pay to move
and get a new car and all that other
kind of crap give me that [__] I'm going
good give me that [__] give me that [__]
Allison says I don't like the people who
also hoard animals I know I hate that
and you always kind of see it too like
the on the show and it's like they have
all these cats or dogs or something like
that I'm like man that's [__] that's
[__] up making those animals live in
those [__] conditions it's like
they've got to be sick you know what I
mean GH it's awful and they just like
they're they're just living in their own
filth you know you know what I mean cuz
they're just like oh we're just going to
let the dogs and stuff like [__] all
over the floor it's
horrifying like I said if you want to
live like that fine but it's I mean
that's not great either obviously but
because they don't know what they're
doing but don't
[__] voice that on the animals they
don't
know um tequila says Hey guys you're
doing my show God here late but so
excited I'm glad you're excited we
haven't got too too much into it but we
have started talking about it which is
crazy because we don't usually start
talking about the actual topic thisly
early but we did actually but we haven't
even got to I went over the murders a
little bit but we're going to get like
more into it as we go on we're just
talking about margerie and then when we
got
into the whole thing about her um
spending problem then we kind of got off
in talking about hoarders so you know
what I mean so there was that but yeah
and I get because like I said I think
one of the justification she gave like
later on because she did kind of admit
yeah you know I have a spending problem
she's like but she grew up wealthy so I
guess her entire childhood she didn't
worry about money because she could just
have whatever she wanted she would just
say hey I want this and her mom would
get it for her so you know she didn't
really have any boundaries or anything
so I guess when she got older she was
just acting
like well I can just have whatever I
want you know not blaming her mom I'm
just saying if you grow up like that and
then you don't have as much money when
you get older it might be kind of hard
to adjust to because are used to just
like buying whatever you want so maybe
that's true but uh but yeah so poor old
dick
looy um put up with her [__] for 20
years
um but the whole time like I said
they're pretty much going deeper and
deeper and deeper into debt I don't
think he really knew the extent of
it and it was softened somewhat by the
fact that her mom Elizabeth would bail
them out most of the time like he would
go and ask her hey you know we got this
bill for you know $112,000 and I can't
pay it and she would write him a check
so it so it was kind of like that so
they kind of sustained but after a while
he was just kind of like look I just
can't I can't deal with this anymore I
mean they had seven kids and I think he
hung around because of that um because I
think he did say later that he's like
well I didn't really want to abandon the
kids you know what I mean but finally
like after 20 years he was just kind of
like um yeah no I'm I'm out of here so
he actually filed for divorce uh in the
early 1970s um I think the divorce was
finalized in
1971 um they determined later and I
think this is an
estimate that over the course of the
marriage uh she had probably spent about
a million dollar in back then money
which which I don't even know how much
that would be in 2023 so like in from
1951 to 1971 they were married over that
time they think that she spent at least
a million dollars in back then
money um one of the things that she
bought and they went a lot into this in
Glen Sheen's daughter the book that I
read that that um te kilip set one of
the things that she
was because this lady she was not only
like a horse girl but she was also like
a weird stage
mom she got all of her kids her seven
kids she enrolled all of them in ice
skating classes and she wanted them all
to be like [__] Champions man yeah so
and that's not cheap I mean you know so
seven kids she pays for all of them to
go to these ice skating classes she buys
them all of these costumes um like
custom costumes and all this other kind
of [__] um and that costs a lot of money
too and she got all of them into horse
riding also the fan is send you the book
is in the comment section yeah yeah yeah
I know you weren't you weren't here for
a long time I already I already
addressed it um yeah he said I'm
planning a trip up to the mansion in a
couple of weeks oh that's awesome like
take some video of it and like send it
to me I'm fascinated I just I I didn't I
I said this earlier like before you got
here but I was just kind of I was so
glad that you sent me this books because
I just finished reading that book like
today like I was taking notes about it
like the whole time and I was just kind
of like I probably never would have
found that case on my own but that [__]
was like fascinating I was like so into
it you
know um let's see Allison says
um Jenny did or would you guys ever
cover the um papin pin sisters murders
didn't did we talk about that it sounds
kind of familiar but I'd have to look it
up um but if if we haven't done it then
we would probably do it yet there's not
enough there for us to remember who that
was yeah it sounds familiar though got
the two twins that went crazy that's
what I thought I thought it was which I
think we covered we did a show about
like like twins or twin psychosis or
mass or yeah like um what's that what do
they call that what they call it uh
fiad yeah Madness shared by two we might
have done a show about that where we
talked about it but I'm not really sure
so I would have to look it up um yeah
Zach says oh that would
be 7.7 million
today apparently so they think that
that's how much she spent over the
course of the marriage um like it was $1
million and back then money but like I
said that's and she wasn't even that
fine
no well see that's the thing did I say
this like before we started the show I
was
like not to be not to be crass or
anything like that but it's just it
seemed
like she was able to just like
manipulate people into doing [__] yeah
even she wasn't super hot or anything
like that I don't really
know I think put like her kids were like
scared of her yeah so I don't know if
there was something else going onw man
don't let a woman run through $7.7
Million worth of your money she's not
fine she's fine you might have an excuse
when she's not fine still don't I mean
don't do it yeah especially if it's just
like buying a bunch of [__] you know
a bunch of [__] I skating kids and
[__] and the thing about margorie is
that and she used this as a defense at
her later trial was that all that money
I spent you know she gave it as an
excuse well you know I grew up rich so I
didn't really know how to handle money
which like I said that's okay that's
understandable but she also said oh most
of the money I spent wasn't even on me
it was on her kids which in a way is
kind of true she did spend a [__] ton of
money getting all of her kids into the
ice skating [__] now it seems like only
they all kind of liked it I guess some
of them were just like I don't really
want to do it I didn't give a [__] her
one son stevenh was real into it though
and he apparently was like real good at
it and he won a bunch of competitions
and stuff but the thing about it was
that I will note and this is not proven
or anything like that but in the book
some of the other people that she knew
like the other parents of the other kids
that were ice skating at the same place
where her kids were being trained um
suspected that she might have been
perhaps sabotaging the other children um
like stealing their custom ice skates or
[__] with their skates so that her
son Steven would always win um they
couldn't prove it but a lot of the
parents there did think that she was up
to some [__] I also thought this was
interesting so she had their costumes
custom made if she saw some fabric she
liked in a store she would buy all of it
so that none of the other parents could
have it so her hers would always stand
out yeah also she had a seamstress make
them but she would have the seamstress
leave the hems UND done so she could
take the costumes to the training place
and sew the Hem so it looked like she
had made the whole things
herself oh so that should give you some
idea ofic personality that's what I was
thinking that's what I was sounds like
histrionic personality that's what I was
trying to think of yeah thank you I knew
you would come up with it if I that's
what that sounds like yeah cuz I was
just like that's I now like I said
there's no proof that she [__] with
the other kids Gates or anything like
that but a lot of the parents there did
seem to
supect this is Jenny's real Hair by the
way look how pretty her real hair is
when it's clean yeah when it's clean she
got real Prett well it's like sometimes
I don't feel like washing it so I just
put a wig over
yeah cuz it's pain in the Apple she got
PR got pretty hair got pretty do you
need me to uh trim need there eventually
yeah cuz I haven't done it for a while
so it's kind of long yeah might need to
like yeah but so I just TS look good
though yeah they're a little bit I think
they're kind they're mostly straight I
like yeah I like that they look better
when they're shorter
um but yeah so that was just like a
little detail I wanted to write down cuz
I was like well that is really
emblematic of the kind of personality
that we're talking about very much into
her appearance like how she looked you
know what I mean and apparently she was
real um strict on the kids like she
wanted she was one of those like I said
it's kind of like pageant moms you know
what I mean where they're just kind of
like uh you they're living vicariously
through their kids so they want their
kids to be like super awesome so they're
like really hard on them history IC
personality disord is like narcissistic
personality disorder but it it it's it's
one of the varieties of that but one of
the things is is they they like to make
themselves look a lot better than they
really are they like to think that
everybody's out for them that that all
men want to sleep with them it's it's
usually a woman thing
um yeah attention horror that's that's
that that's one of the main things with
which those kind of people drive me
[__] crazy I can't vicariously
through children narcissistic
personality disorder that's where the
children is nothing more than just a
reflection of her yeah that so I
definitely got a VI mom that kind I got
a vibe from that from the whole like
from the whole time when she was like
making them do horse riding and making
them do ice skating like I said most of
the kids really didn't give a [__] one
way or the other about it but the one
son was kind of into it although he put
later on they tend to have a real fake
feeling facade to them yeah I got that's
definitely the vibe I got from reading
about her yeah um yeah tequil said they
made a yeah I wanted to bring that up
they did make a movie at Glen Sheen
Mansion this was when um this was in
1972 I believe when Elizabeth was still
alive uh they shot a movie there called
you'll like my mother uh it had Patty
Duke in it and the weird thing about it
was that it was like a thriller like
about somebody going to meet their
mother-in-law and then there was like a
murder involved and stuff and it's just
kind of like oh 5 years later H
something kind of similar happened you
know what I mean there was for sure a
murder so yeah I thought that was like
pretty weird it might be a good movie I
don't know I never heard of it before
but uh but so yeah now right around this
time period
too um a house that she owned
mysteriously burned down H wonder what
that could be
about insurance wires got crossed yeah
oh there's a lot of that will be
happening later there's a lot she wasn't
even trying to like [__] hide it at
some point um but yeah I don't know if
this was the first time that she
allegedly did this but she didn't get I
mean she was suspected but they didn't
really have enough to prove it so it
just kind of didn't go anywhere but that
was around this time
too now at this point so her husband
dick has divorced her after 20 years
like I said they have seven kids like a
lot of them are grown at this stage but
I think she still had three or four of
them with her that were still younger
teenagers so she moves to Colorado now I
believe her um Elizabeth Conan's dad
Chester conden I think he also had some
land and property and stuff in Colorado
so that or maybe it was Arizona but I
can't remember that's why she moved out
there so she meets her second victim I
mean husband no he's a victim in yeah
well in 1975 now this was Roger
Caldwell she actually met him she'd been
going to this like self-help group or
like a you know kind of um meeting thing
for Parents Without Partners I don't
even know if they have that anymore but
they had that back in the 70s like
somebody got divorced or widowed or
something like that and they would go
and it was just like a singles type of
thing um now apparently he thought she
was quite awesome uh she was very
outgoing and stuff he was a little more
reserved uh some would
say maybe um able to be manipulated I
would never say that but you know some
have said that so they got married I
believe only 2 months after they met
which is
insane now this the thing is after she
married him now he said later on that um
he did not know that she was an Aris he
didn't know that she had all this money
that coming to her after her mom died
and blahy blah like she didn't tell him
that at first I don't know if that's
true but that's what he
said but apparently after they married
she did pretty much the same [__] that
she was doing when she was married to
Old dick dick ly um just spending and
spending and spending and kind of going
to Mom
whenever uh you know whenever they got
into Jam you know um she had had a fund
at some point like a trust fund like I
said she had more than one she had some
that were I can't remember what all the
details were but she had like there was
a bunch of them that were set up by the
family like to make sure that all the
relatives were taken care of right so
some of the trust were like okay well
after the person turns 18 they'll get
this much every month or after the
person turns 35 they'll get this month
or after this person dies they'll get
this much you know what I mean so it was
that so she had several so she had like
a trust fund that I think had a few
million dollars in it she blew through
most of that um I think after she
married Roger Caldwell she spent another
million out of that she was getting a
monthly income as well which I believe
was $4,800 but I'm not real sure so said
she sounds kind of like a Joan Crawford
kind of a m yeah I mean she does kind of
sound like kind of but I'm going to
disagree a little bit Joan Crawford was
competent she was a great actress under
a lot of pressure because she did not
want to be be a poor person again she
kind of was self-made and came from
nothing and the way Hollywood was
Hollywood was [__] brutal so yeah she
she just did not want standards to slip
and she knew her career was falling
apart you got to see Mommy Dearest it's
a great movie you guys haven't seen I
love that movie
um but she was not
histrionic I mean histrionic people with
histrionic personality disorder and this
type of disorders like narcissistic they
tend to be actually be to be incompetent
they're not they're not
competent that's the
tendency yeah I see yeah I you know what
I'm talking about Crawford actually was
defending greatness because she was
falling apart she was getting older as
an actress and in Hollywood that's a
[__] death sentence
that's what her problem was she just
getting older not allowed to get older
especially if you're a lady not in that
era nope not in that era you start
getting a little little bit of a wrinkle
somewhere they're like nope out you go
and she was a great actress and a sex
symbol yeah so she was under a lot of
pressure she took it out on her kids I
mean there might be some overlap though
because I was going to say that Joan
Crawford was allegedly physically and
mentally abusive to her adopted children
and I was going to say I don't think
Marjorie was physically abusive but then
I remembered that somebody in the book
like one of her kids had said that her
that she had tried to like strangle her
at one point yeah Crawford may have had
a narcissistic personality yeah and and
a disorder behind it but
it it's not exactly what this is so far
from what I'm hearing yeah I mean you'll
see how it how it gets you might get
kind of a thing she has money by
accident she didn't earn
yeah she just got was lucky enough to
get adopted into like a super super
wealthy family and was brought up like
that Joan made her money yeah okay like
through her own right sure through her
own prowess which like I said you do
even though she was
arguably uh pretty messed up later on
but you you do have to give her that I
mean she clawed her way up from pretty
much nothing in a really rough time yeah
in a time where and she probably had to
do a bunch of [__] up [__] yeah to get
where she lot of casting action oh I'm
sure yeah and uh as I've said
before the women that become Hollywood
stars in those days if they weren't
Stars they would have been prostitutes
that's probably what they would have
been um because that would be and that's
kind of where they would go back to if
they lost their career yeah so she was
fighting to stay above all that so was
under a lot she wasn't under normal
modern
pressures you know but one of the things
that is similar is that I do get the
impression that Joan Crawford also
adopted those kids to look good to look
good yeah of
course yeah um so well I mean it's
slightly a different situation because
Elizabeth conden the woman that got
murdered yeah I don't think she didn't
adopt the kids to look good she didn't
give a [__] about that like nobody ever
said that about her they said she was
was very private she didn't she gave all
this money to charity and didn't want
any publicity about it or anything she
adopted the kids cuz she wanted them
right um now margorie was different but
she naturally had all those kids she
didn't adopt those kids that those were
her seven kids she pumped out and but
she used them for sure the same way that
Joan Crawford allegedly used her kids
like for like I said like a pageant mom
she came across kind of like a pageant
mom well I think Joe needed kids for a
shield
because against the the paparazzi of the
time to make her look like she wasn't a
[__] that she wasn't
available you know what I'm talking
about now were there cuz I know this she
had husbands didn't she I think might
have been married but I don't think she
had well she was married to the CEO of
Pepsi yeah remember that's right yeah
and then she was on the board like after
he
died and they W I think Joan dated a lot
and she didn't want to look like she was
dating so she had that was kind of like
a I don't think Scandal people don't
really give much of a [__] about it
nowadays but it's like back in the days
of old Hollywood it's like if you were
rumored to be like gay or lesbian or
like slept around or something like that
like a lot of times in studios be like
you need to look like little Miss happy
homaker family thing um because
otherwise nobody's going to come see
your movies because they're going to
think you're gay or you're a ho or
something like that so a lot of there
were a lot of arranged marriages and
[__] like that I was like one I can't
remember what his name was but I wrote
about a case like an actor kind of like
a b tier actor like from the Golden Era
of Hollywood he was gay and he actually
married his lesbian best friend just so
they could look you know she was like a
beard yeah I mean they knew what was
going on like they went into it just so
he wouldn't like lose jobs there were a
few
Hollywood stars female stars that got
the ho angle to work for him one of them
would be May West yeah and she was a
gagster gagster girlfriend and she knew
how to work it and she was [__] [__]
funny we've kind of been wanting to do a
show about her actually I love maywe she
was open about what she did but I feel
she could only get away with that like
only she got away with that yeah a lot
of people did not and they put her in
roles that fit that character yeah but
she was open about interracial
relationships open about dating dudes
and [__] them and not being married
she was open about that yeah Marlene
Dietrich was pretty open about being a
lesbian yeah
um but there were only very few that
could do that yeah it seemed like it
almost seemed like there were exceptions
yeah but most of them could not get away
with it you couldn't play that role and
then
be you couldn't be that openly and then
play like a housewife yeah you could
only play certain Ty a bad girl you had
to play a villain or like you know you
couldn't be like the anine yeah right
yeah no like because no one would buy it
they didn't want to see which I get that
so they were just like type cting they
were typ cast is what it was but as long
as you played a character that was like
that that was like [__] or whatever
they're like all right that that tracks
West played [__] but funny yeah and
everybody liked her yeah yeah she
totally got away with that TR like I
said we should do a show about her would
do a whole show cuz I love her and she's
she wasn't pretty she was short and sexy
and funny not pretty though but you'd
hit if you were a guy just because she
was attractive I would also hit she
would hit yeah actually I think she
probably would be open into that too
that's what I mean see I like that I
like that I like that
openness yeah but yeah okay so where was
I all right so so yeah so as far as I
know at this point like margorie has
blown through a few million dollars that
came out of her trust fund you know she
was getting a stipend every month like
all of that kind of stuff but she's for
sure like spent way more than she should
have been spending there was that um she
would pay for [__] like with checks the
checks would bounce she would go to her
mom mom and her mom would indulge her as
always um which she probably shouldn't
have done but you know she like I said
she was that kind of
lady um but at this point um in the mid
1970s Elizabeth conden had a
stroke and at this point she needed
nursing care like around the clock um
and at this point the she had um I
believe it was three Trustees of her
state that were you know supervising
[__] and like seeing that it went to the
right people and whatever and at this
point the trustees stepped in and said
we are not giving Marjorie any more
money because she's obviously spending
all of it and this wasn't what was
intended you know what I mean um cuz
margerie would come there and be like
hey I need $50,000 for this or you know
$100,000 for that and at this point like
her mom would be like okay and would
write her a check but at this point the
trustees are like okay now that you know
Elizabeth is she wasn't you know she was
indisposed I guess um but they're like
at this point we're just like not we're
going to advise you to like not give her
any more money because she's just
blowing all of
it so at this stage it's
1977 and margerie and her husband Roger
are pretty much broke because they've
been cut off
essentially uh their house got
foreclosed on um they had several cars
all of which were
repossessed but for whatever reason well
I know what probably the reason is but
margorie still held on to this Pie in
the Sky kind of fantasy that she still
was rich so she would call real estate
agents and be like hey I'm going to go
I'm going to go look at this ranch we're
going to buy this Ranch that's like a
million dollars and she would go and
tour it and then she'd say oh I have all
this money coming you know in in my
trust and it's like that's what I'm
going to pay for for this with but she
would go into T it like almost like she
was dreaming about this [__] life
that she obviously could not afford
anymore um and she's like yeah my mom is
going to pay for all of it and at this
point um they wanted to buy a ranch one
of her excuses was why they moved out to
the Southwest was because at this point
her I believe it was her youngest son
whose name was Rick who at this point
was 17 um he had really bad asthma and
like mother health problems and so she
said that his doctors had advised them
to like move somewhere warmer because
they were from Minnesota you know what I
mean so it's like the cold weather was
exacerbating the asthma blah blah I
don't know if that was true but they're
like okay we want to live like where
it's kind of warm and dry so they are
wanting to move uh to
Colorado now so as I said this is 1977
and at this point they've pretty much
come to the point where they don't
really have any money left and this is
right around the time that the murder
happened
so in June of
1977 marjorie's mom Elizabeth um she was
on in her bedroom on the second floor in
you know in Minnesota in Glen
Sheen now across the hall from her was
where her nurse would stay now she had
several nurses obviously that would come
in like for long shifts or whatever now
on this particular night the nurse was
named Velma patila I think is how you
pronounce her last name patila or pitia
I'm not really sure I think it's just
one L so that's just usually like an L
right I thought it was Double L if it
had to be if it was like a y sound but I
can't remember two L's probably that's
what I thought but she her name only has
one L so I think it's patila okay so she
was the nurse on duty that night this
[__] saddest thing one of the saddest
things about this to me Velma had
actually been miss Conan's nurse for a
long time but she had retired a month
before the only reason she was working
this particular particular night was
because the W the nurse that would
normally be there had like some other
[__] going on and couldn't come and so
they had asked Velma to come back even
though she'd been retired for a month um
and Velma hated working the night like
the overnight shift and her husband was
like man please don't go it's like you
know what I mean it's like you've been
retired please stay retired you know
what I mean like she wanted to hang out
with her husband they wanted to like
have retirement together um but she's
like no I'll just do it this one
time that just makes me so sad
cuz spoiler alert she got murdered so
she was only there for this one night
because she had to fill
in now so she
basically is there that night and the
lady is there I
think there was only I think there was
one only one other staff member that
lived in the house which I believe was
the cook they had some other staff
members was like a grounds keeper and
stuff like that but they didn't live in
the actual house I think they lived in
other buildings like on the property you
know what I mean cuz it's like an estate
so I think there were only maybe maximum
three people in the house this
particular night I'm not entirely sure
if that's true but that's the impression
that I
got the next morning early like 7:00
a.m. the day nurse arrives to relieve
the Night Nurse her name is Mildred
garw she comes to the house and the
front door is unlocked which she finds
very
unusual so she kind of stops in she says
hi to the Cook who's in the kitchen kit
you know the cook doesn't seem to
nothing a miss and then she starts going
up the stairs
toward um Elizabeth's bedroom and she
sees um Velma lying on like on the
landing of the staircase cuz I saw
pictures of it there's like a like a
window seat like a long Window Seat a
bench and she's laying on
there and Mildred's kind of like well
that's really weird is she like sleeping
or what's that about you know what I
mean so she comes up closer and then
sees that she's basically covered with
blood um and is clearly quite
dead so she freaks out runs up the rest
of the stairs to Elizabeth's
bedroom and goes in there and Elizabeth
is laying there in her bed with this
pink satin pillow that had like a thing
of blood on it like just it was still
over her face and she had clearly been
smothered with it the room was also in
massive disarray uh it looked like
somebody had ransacked the place uh
there was just jewelry all over the
floor um other pillows and [__] like
that just like all over the place so
like I said it looked like somebody had
come in and like robbed them and like
and killed the
women so Mildred runs back down
downstairs and calls the police
obviously at this point they did not
know if the killer was still in the
house or not because they didn't know
when this had happened so uh so
basically the you know the nurse she's
stays on the phone just in case you know
the the dude is still in the house or
whatever so the cops show up now they
didn't find it they went through the
house obviously the killer was
gone they thought at the at that stage
that the killer had gained entry by
breaking a window in the billiard room
on the lowest level of the house cuz
what there was from what from the
description and like I saw the um the
blueprints of what they were talking
about there was kind of like an outdoor
like a not like a screen in porch but
like an outdoor porchy patio kind of
area like along the back of the house
and the windows had been taken out of
that for whatever reason I don't know if
they were repairing ing them or if they
just did that for the season or whatever
so they thought that the killer had just
climbed in through that window and then
had maybe punched in or busted in with a
rock like the window into the billiard
room and then had gone up the stairs
they said apparently they were maybe
just intending to rans sack Elizabeth's
room and steal her [__] um but then like
the maid or the nurse rather had
confronted them on the stairs at which
point they busted her head in with a
brass Candlestick which was kind of th
in there you know what I mean so they
think that that's kind of what
happened um so yeah she had a fractured
skull it was it was a mess now they did
find the cops um they did an okay job I
feel like they maybe didn't do a great
job but okay they did find a few strands
of dark hair in the nurse's hand like
clutched in the hand like she had fought
with her attacker now she had black hair
as well so they didn't know if it was
hers
but um because it was 1977 so they
didn't have like the forensic [__] that
we have
nowadays so they um there were a couple
things missing from Elizabeth's
room um there was the diamond ring that
she always wore on her finger was gone
the gold watch that she always had on
her wrist was also gone and later on and
this was pretty
weird there was a she had this ancient
coin it was like a Byzantine era coin so
it was like thousands a couple thousand
years
old that was also missing 1700 that was
also missing
yeah so and there was also like this
wicker basket that had been in the room
that was also
gone so they thought that the person
like I said had broken in through the
billiard room gone up the stairs met the
nurse on the stairs and then when she
started screaming or whatever like
busted her in the head then went up and
smothered Elizabeth and then ransacked
the room took all the [__] they also
thought that he had gone into a little
bathroom across the hall um and washed
up they didn't find any fingerprints in
there but they did find like some blood
residue now then he apparently went
through the purse of the nurse that he
just killed Velma and found her car keys
and stole her car so there's that too
and also left the door of the house
unlocked as he
left
now at first the cops came out and said
well it's obviously a burglary gone
wrong you know what I
mean so there was that now they did
later find the nurse's car and it was
parked at Minneapolis St Paul Airport
but it was parked in like a pretty
obvious place place it wasn't like they
were didn't look like the killer was
trying to hide it or anything and then
in a garbage can at the airport they
found the car keys and like the parking
ticket for the car so I thought that was
a little
weird so three days after the murder
they have Elizabeth's funeral and all of
the family members come
there now when Roger Caldwell margery's
husband shows up at the
funeral um he apparently had some
bruises and stuff and like cuts on it
like he had a split lip and [__] like
that so people were like asking about
that and he said oh I got kicked by a
horse which no seems unlikely I've been
kicked by a horse it doesn't do that to
you if a horse kicked you in your face
you'd be knock you the [__] out you'd
have black eyes [__] missing teeth
broken
nose stop it like I said yeah just
bruises in a little Split Lip seems a
little silly no I got kicked in the ch
chest one time it threw me about 20 ft
30 ft lucky to have survived it yeah
Oracle said you'd be spitting teeth yeah
yeah you think I mean that's a horse
exactly they are [__] strong stronger
than any man well they can kill you they
can kill you just kicking you like that
I got kicked in the [__] center of
the chest [__] threw me about [__]
you're lucky you didn't like I woke up a
few seconds later look in the horse
running at me [__] making fun of me
yeah I got you [__] I got
you this is like God damn dude I'm all L
leave me alone you [__] you're a lot
bigger than I am so yeah so they thought
that was a little weird um also margorie
was at the funeral like margerie and
Roger were both at the funeral and
people and this isn't um you know
obviously this doesn't uh this isn't an
admission of guilt or anything but they
did say that Marjorie was kind of I
don't know if I'd say cheerful but they
seemed like she was kind of in High
Spirits at the funeral and she was kind
of dressed
inappropriately uh in the book they said
she was wearing white slacks and like a
blue and white flowered blouse which
doesn't seem very ferally does it so
they thought that was a little
strange now so the two of them they came
for the funeral people thought that they
were acting a little weird um and then
they left duth and went back to
miniapolis St Paul and they stayed at
this hotel now weirdly while they were
at the hotel Roger Caldwell the husband
he like blacked out and he got taken to
the hospital now when they investigated
what like what had caused that he had a
whole bunch of sedatives in his system
hm isn't that
fishy but he lived I mean you know he
was fine but it was just like a little
bit
weird so the cops at first even though
they said to the public it's like well
it looks like a botch burglary but
behind the scenes they were kind of
suspecting some different [__] because
as soon as it went public that Elizabeth
Conan had been murdered several of the
conden family called the police and said
margerie did it basically um they
basically said look into margerie and
Roger because they were in a [__] ton of
debt they just got cut off by the
trustees um you know she was in line to
I think her on her um mom's death she
was supposed to get I think it was 8.4
million um so there was that uh and
matter of fact when they called
Jennifer um you know the the sister the
they said the first words out of her
mouth when they called her and said your
mom's dead your mom got murdered the
first words out of her mouth were
Marjorie did it that's what she
said and as the police in looked into
this
possibility family members were telling
them some kind of interesting things
about margerie for example many years
prior um I believe it was in 1971 or
1972 or maybe it was 1973 I can't
remember exactly but it was like you
know a couple years prior to the
murder um there had been a big family
gathering I believe it was at Glenn
Sheen and Elizabeth the mom had gotten
really really sick and then one of the
family members said you know um It's the
funniest thing but margerie had brought
some homemade orange marmalade that
she'd made and she insisted on her mom
eating it even though her mom was
diabetic like she's like oh a little bit
won't hurt her I'm going to make her a
sandwich and blahy
blah now when they did kind of tests
later on when you know cuz she was real
sick and she went to the hospital they
found like all of these sedatives like
in her bloodstream which were the same
sedatives that were found in Rogers
bloodstream like apy because I think
allegedly after the murder happened of
Elizabeth I think that Marjorie was like
oh well I don't need Roger anymore so
I'm going to bump him off cuz that was
kind of hurt emo did they test marmalade
no well they couldn't find well see
nobody reported it at the time because
they didn't I think like only a family
member just thought it was funny and
they didn't really think about it after
that so they didn't have the jar they
didn't have anything like that I love
orange marmalade I know you do um the
thing is though is that it's not very
efficient to dose an entire jar of
marmalade with what it would take to
[__] kill a
person because they're only going to eat
a little bit of that
marmalade you know what I'm talking
about I guarantee it was marmalade she
was poisoned she was poisoned another
way maybe te or what she was drinking
what I heard was that the particular
sedatives that she was using were super
bitter tasting and she always used
marmalade because it masked the flavor
better because it was super tart but
maybe it was in the drink it could have
been like I said but I'm just saying
that a lot of the family members had
suspected Marjorie of being up to some
Shenanigans like prior to this you know
what I mean they just remember jelly
they're not using very much so that
means that most of the poison that
you're using or stive is is unused it's
in the damn marble a jar yeah so how
much is it going to
take and then you got the jar left over
they never did find but like I said
nobody reported it so maybe they maybe
she Gra the cuz she didn't die right
they just it's just that she got real
sick right and then somebody remembered
hey Marjorie was like really insistent
on giving her this marmalade so maybe
that had something to do with it you
know what I mean but they didn't think
about that until what happens when you
cook the sedative in with the marmalade
you know what I mean because it's cooked
first does it destroy it I don't know I
think she's pois she was I'm sure she
had a sedative put it into her you said
there was evidence of that yeah probably
wasn't like there was a very high
concentration probably wasn't a mar
though probably direct somehow there was
another way it's possible well like I
said we'll we'll see what you what you
say like after all of it
um I just out the top of my head it's
hard to poison
food they taste it well that's a cook
that's yeah and I know all about drugs
well I mean not not to scare you or
anything but I have read several books
about poisons and it's like there are
particular ones that poisoners use for
the reason that you can't really taste
yeah right and if you mix it with
particular things it masks the flavor
really well but a lot of poisons you do
kind of have to watch because they you
can taste
it yeah but then there's also the amount
that it takes yeah that's and that's
another that's a big factor that's
another thing right and the well okay so
I don't know because this isn't proven
like I said she was never convicted of
anything so or she was convicted of
stuff but not this but the book Glen
Sheen's daughter speculated that she had
been been trying to kill her mom back
then but had gotten the dosage wrong
because it just kind of made her mom
sick it didn't kill her obviously and I
that was a couple years before the
actual
murder so that was what they were
speculating but I don't know if that's
true or not it's just but everybody in
the family thought that though they
suspected her of doing some [__] because
I guess they knew how she was and they
knew that she was always in debt and she
had this really lavish lifestyle that
she couldn't afford and so she kind of
had a motive for bumping the old lady
off you know what I mean so she could
get the money cuz she had a bunch of
money coming to her like even though she
had blown through a lot of the trust I'm
going to say but I think she was still
up for 8.4 million women have always
notoriously been
poisoners well it's easy well it's not
easy you have to it's not easy it's also
not reliable no but but they have been
doing it for a long time especially back
in the 1800s it's easier to get away
with [__] it's easier to get away with
me being a male ex
Soldier knowing all about Black
Operations and
[__] drug cartels and [__] the way
shit's done through the CIA the best way
is always blunt force
trauma blunt force trauma is always the
most effective if you're trying to hide
the fact that a Mur was done and the
best blood force trauma is the
fall C that's why the CIA tradition Ally
when they killed somebody your
intelligence agency killed somebody
usually they just threw them out of a
window well yeah I mean that seems like
to me it's the best way and depending on
where you're at I was like wouldn't it
just be easier to like push someone down
the stairs or like off a cliff or some
[__] like that like depending on where
you were so it wouldn't look suspicious
classic or have somebody fall out the
window whoops classic Intel operatives
would throw somebody out of the window
and leave the window open don't like
shoot them or beat them to death or
something like that leaves too much you
know it's a Mur murder that's what I
mean you throw them out a window you
have plausible deniability say well it
was suicide it was suicide sure but that
was the old era before cameras mhm
nowadays they would see the team walking
in and out of the building possibly in
and out of the room you have to be super
sneaky now you have to really know the
layout it's a lot harder to get away
with crimes nowadays which is good I
mean that's good in some ways having
these security cameras around helps you
cuz [__] man like reading about a lot of
the crimes that happen cuz I'm
fascinated by like poisoner crimes I
don't know why but um a lot of the
poisoner crimes that happen like in the
late 19th century man you could get away
with [__] anything back then well
holy [__] look at like [__] Jack the
Ripper he had he didn't even do
poisoning he just like in the [__]
middle of the street and he just like
gutted women in the middle of the street
and nobody [__] caught him another
backup instead of throwing somebody out
of the window probably be [__] hit
and run steal a car and run somebody
over also plausible but still yeah still
too messy yeah but they know somebody
was hit and run but they just can't see
who it was it might have been an
accident you know what I mean [__]
plausible deniability like I said I
would rather just maybe the person just
stepped out of the [__] road out on
the road at the wrong time but really
what it was is it was a hit team that
[__] ran you
over you know it it happens they still
do it yeah I'm just saying I don't even
know if I would risk that another one
that they do four or five guys grab you
take you to a wooded area and shoot you
in the side of the head throw the weapon
on the ground the fake suicide Noe you
went out in the woods and killed
yourself yeah yeah I mean as long as
there's yeah a question about look up my
buddy Timothy Tim van vakia so went is
the army with him he was in a hit team
like that he's all over the internet I
can show you pictures of me and Tim
together and that's what they did he and
his team killed hundreds of people in
Central and South America
i' behest of the governments in the in
those countries and it was [__] like
that they would show up as cops and
arrest
you in a real cop car take you out the
woods and [__] shoot you and throw
you into a [__] pre-dug
hole Yeah you disappear death squad
stuff Tim van vacus Timothy van vacus
look him up he's in prison right now
he'll be out though be out in a couple
years yeah Oracle talking about it says
as a diabetic yeah that's a red flag
like somebody saying hey you can eat
this it's fine I'd be like yeah are you
trying to poison me [__] uh my dad was a
diabetic man he [__] broke those
rules all the [__] time he died 77 my
grandfather was also a diabetic yeah and
he was constantly sneaking sneaking [__]
little Debbies and stuff like when he
could still move around like he would
cuz it was a 7-Eleven right next to
their house um and he would just like go
over there and buy little Debbies and
whatnot we and he would eat him in his
car he would sit in his car and eat him
and then stuff the the rapper under the
cuz I had to drive his car one time cuz
my car broke down and um there was all
there was like little debut rappers like
all underneath the [__] the car seat
my dad injected himself with insulin all
the time he had the diabetes and he was
the same way he ate pretty normally and
his explanation was and he got it early
30s he's like what the [__] is the point
of living if you can't live I says I'm
going to eat what I want to eat I mean
I'll just keep it low yeah and he lived
to 77 and I mean that's probably a good
way to approach anything because it's
like man if I couldn't eat like some
treats or something good like every now
and then like yeah what would be the
[__] point of it cuz I really enjoy
that but you just got to kind of keep it
on the down low you can't just yeah
stuff yourself with it yeah yeah Oracle
said if I ever eat something to carb
heavy my husband gives me a
look uh also says my other question is
does the pH of the marmalade affect the
Poison's efficacy oh you know see this
is a lot of the stuff that you got to
like think about that's why I said
poisoning is not easy that's why I think
a lot of serious poisoners I think they
try [__] out sadly on animals like on
mice and rats and stuff like before well
small doses won't kill you they probably
taste it too yeah and then they spit it
out they go yeah that's okay
yeah uh tequil who is the one who sent
us the books uh didn't y'all do a show
on that Italian chick that poisoned a
bunch of people and then made them into
magical soap or something yeah was she
Italian or was she
Mexican I think she I think she was
Italian but I have to go back and think
about it yeah that was a while back but
yeah that was a [__] crazy ass story
you said Mexican man I thought about
that Mexican restaurant up the road we
should go to that maybe we can go
tomorrow we haven't been in a while huh
no I haven't I haven't been I got a real
Mexican restaurant went without me a
couple times so I I haven't been I don't
think I've been since that chick was
here yeah yeah that's right and how many
years has that been oh been many years
so I don't it's a lot better than it was
they got so I haven't even we got a real
Mexican restaurant over here in the
middle of the country well it's a it's
half a restaurant and half a Mexican
grocery store yeah and uh most of the
guys that work in this area are not
really Mexican but they are Central
American they eat a lot of same food you
know uh you know Honduras you know
[__] Guatemala [__] whatever um
Salvador and [__] the food is [__]
great man it's Mexican food but like I
said I haven't been there in forever
yeah and it it's authentic and it's all
the guys that are all the farm hands
around
here they eat there that's where Tom
used to he used to ride up there on his
motorcycle just specifically to get that
hot sauce that brown hot sauce because
they stopped carrying it at Walmart some
some Walmarts carry it sometimes they
have it you yeah you could you could
like the super hot brown
[__] it's got a damn Mayan name so he
go to Walmart it's like oh they don't
have it today so then he'd ride up to
he'd ride up to the Mexican grocery
store cuz they that restaurant is not
not cheap it's expensive but it looks
like a little diner I was showing to con
oon my Mexican friend then Tiana show
him what I was getting he goes yeah
that's it man that [__] is good [__]
it's it's I don't I think you've been
there a time or two since then but I
don't think I've been there since what
was that girl's name uh [__] I I forgot
now I remember in a minute that girl
that was staying with us from England
yeah yeah yeah she's a British uh Muslim
girl yeah from Pakistan British
Pakistani girl she was [__] hilarious
we meet her I don't even remember I knew
her online oh okay and she she was
coming here and she was coming to
Florida and we said okay we had a spare
room you she married now yeah married a
an Anglo British guy and he had they had
a for several days yeah we took her to
we took her to CH took her to the club
and sh she was [__] naughty as [__]
it's like she had the Catholic school
girl problem she did yeah
damn Aisha Aisha that's right yeah yeah
I remembered it at the same time you did
yeah Aisha that's right yeah she was I
think that we took her to that Mexican
place but I think that's the last time I
yeah and it wasn't that good then it's
better it was pretty good but it wasn't
the best wacamole their wacamole is
[__] awesome [__] man now you got to
take you got to take me there tomorrow
we'll go tomorrow either that or we'll
go back to that tie place I thought you
had to return some [__] up by where that
tie place is I do okay we can do both
all right tomorrow's what Thursday
Thursday we got to do gym and we'll uh
um go to Mexican place and we'll
uh drop off the the mail yeah returns
cuz I said before we found a really good
tie place that doesn't even look like it
would be a really good tie place cuz
it's in like this hold of the wall
[__] strip it's in the shitty looking
shrip M and we just ended up there like
accidentally cuz the place we were going
to go to wasn't didn't open yeah so I
was like oh well there's another one
like 3 miles from here and then we ended
up like oh my God this is [__]
delicious [__] delicious we're going
to I'm back here great Tie Restaurant
there's a tie couple running it yeah
there's only like three seats in the
whole place the rest of it carry out man
it was so good yeah I was just like I
was thinking I had pad tie and I was
just kind of
like tie red curry and and I got [__]
a Chinese dish I got crab rangon but
they did it Thai style they had [__]
turmeric in there God that [__] was
delici man it was the best [__]
rangon that is the best crab rangon I've
ever had was and I've had a lot of crab
rangon but that was the best it was like
it was like pillowy inside it was like
like they littleit egg or something
fluffy oh so cuz I saw that crab Ron on
there as an appetizer and I was like I'm
going to [__] order something Chinese
in here and see what happens sh [__] man
it was yeah we were like man that's no
joke that was really good that was I
mean easily by far that was the best
crra CRA they're not playing I've ever
had they were not playing that's the
best Pat tie I've ever had too they were
good yeah and I just got it with pork in
it all right so where are we we're about
halfway through we're about halfway
through the story it's okay what's the
time Ben um it's 9:00 so no no 1 hour
ago it says it's an hour and something
so our time's good yeah we're at about
an hour and a half hour 20 minutes so we
might be halfway through it um a little
less than halfway okay thanks for coming
to the show [__] we love our regular
fans we are [__] getting about half
loaded I'm going to make you another
drink here that's only my first drink
honestly is it cuz you just filled it up
with ice you didn't put any more booze
in it I don't no same so that's just
remind you that the super chats are open
and [__] we always love to get super
chats and um [__] make sure to like
share and
subscribe and uh let me go make Jen
another drink yeah share that [__]
around Oscar says how about a show about
the anthrax epidemic in scare where yeah
oh back uh we probably should do that I
know we've done thing yeah I know we've
done one about like the
Tylenol scare that happened back in the
eight was that the 80s yeah I think we
did a show about that like where
everybody's getting poison with the
Tylenol but I don't think we've done a
show about Anthrax so that's a good idea
we probably should do that I'll put that
in the next
poll um Danny says also what ghosts are
haunting this Mansion is the mansion
still haunted I have heard that it's
still haunted I saw one video on YouTube
where they were talking about it um but
like I said I kind of just like I
thought all the [__] about Marjorie was
a lot more interesting there people have
just reported stuff like the most common
thing that I saw reported as far as
hauntings go was that a lot of people
said they heard like screaming like
disembodied screaming from outside the
house and like bangs and stuff when
there was no reason for it that's I've
kind of heard that a lot but other than
that I don't know if anyone's seen any
apparitions or anything like
that um Oracle said yeah she says damn
it y'all are making me hungry I know I'm
getting hungry too um all I've had today
was a bowl of chili like honestly Tom
made some chili with Steph in the garden
and then we last night like he went last
night or night before he went to the
dollar store and got some Fritos and
some some sour cream and so just put the
chili on Fritos and the sour cream it
was like really really good so it was
kind of like nachos uh Oracle said my
husband and I have adopted Two Kitties a
sisters named Freya and Luna they're
three years old a that's so cute you'll
have to send me a picture you have to
send me a picture I wonder if is
um okay our little second Kitty Bambi
our baby is I I don't know if you can
see her she's stand in that damn corner
she's back in the corner like behind if
you can see like this white framed thing
like behind my thing this little shelf
she's all crawled up like sleeping in
the corner like behind that and she's
been there for several several
hours um yeah tequil said supposedly
there's a picture of an apparition in
one of the upstairs window yeah I saw
that and I saw somebody had taken this
weird ass video this was pretty creepy I
kind of wish I had saved it but I didn't
um but it was somebody had taken some
video um on the tour of the
mansion and there's somebody like
blocking most of the
view but behind the person there is what
looks like a mannequin except it's
moving like a person it's kind of hard
to
explain um cuz there's a mannequin over
here like in Period dress or whatever
but everybody that worked at the Mansion
said yeah there's not a mannequin there
but this person or whatever it is like
that's behind that they filmed it's just
kind of like this really weird it was
kind of creepy I don't know if it's
paranormal or not it might have just
been a person that was weird looking and
super skinny but it did kind of look
like there was a mannequin behind this
person in the foreground cuz you could
only see like their arm and like part of
their shoulder and it just looked like a
really skinny woman but it kind of
looked like a mannequin and but it was
moving like a
person and so a lot of people were like
what the [__] was that all about like
they thought that was maybe a ghost or
something but which maybe it is I don't
I don't think so but it it looked creepy
I don't have any explanation for it I
have to say so there was that what the
creepy um no I was saying that somebody
there was a long video about um it was
like a paranormal Channel MH and they
had done the first part of like the
first 20 minutes of it were just a
description of the murders and about the
history of the house and everything and
then it was like a almost like a live
stream with like the three guys and they
were talking about hauntings and [__]
that had been reported at the house and
they showed this video and it's
apparently it's on YouTube so you can
see it but there was a video somebody
took of the Mansion when they were on
the tour there's a person in the
foreground like right here and then
behind that person there's something
that looks like a mannequin but it's
moving like a person but kind of
unnaturally hm like it's pretty creepy
weird and it's like daytime I don't know
what it is it doesn't look ghostly or
nothing but it's like I couldn't really
figure out what it was and like I said
there was another mannequin over here
but everybody that worked at the Mansion
said yeah there's not a mannequin there
so we're not entirely sure what that is
maybe it's just another person and the
person was just like super skinny or
something is that cat going to sleep all
show probably damn she just really likes
to curl up and sleep over there she
always sleeps in mommy's office she is
like Mommy's little Shadow her voices
must be soothing her yeah she's like
seriously she's like my little Shadow
everywhere I go if I get up from my
office to go somewhere hey where you
going where you going and then she tries
to flop and like give me like pet her
stomach and stuff it's hilarious but
yeah she follows me everywhere so I do
call her my little
Shadow but yeah so where were we okay so
the whole thing so so they think that
Marjorie might have maybe perhaps
allegedly try to poison her mom a couple
years before her mom was actually
murdered so you know what I mean a lot
of the family did believe that
so the cops are kind of taking all of
this into account and they're like okay
well we need to like look into all of
this
stuff now they didn't find any
fingerprints um they did find a couple
of palm prints though but I think it
ended up that one of the palm prints
because they were like oh these are
unidentified maybe one of them is The
Killers blah blah but it turned out that
the two unidentified palm prints one of
them belonged to another nurse that
worked there and then the second one
belonged to one of the cops that was
investigating so you know they weren't
super careful as you can
see so um they found as they were doing
the
investigation in a safety deposit box
which belonged to margerie Andor
Roger they found a handwritten will this
will was dated 3 days before the
murders on this will margerie was
signing over $2.5 million
to Roger as I said when her mom died she
was on she was um supposedly going to
receive I believe it was $8.4
Million so the fact that this
handwritten will was found in there
giving him $2.5
million a lot of people speculated that
maybe this was the payment that Marjorie
had gave him or like the incentive like
hey look I'm going to put it in the
safety deposit box I signed it and
everything like that if you'll bump off
my m
then I'll cut you off a SCE I'll give
you like $2.5 million that's what
everybody kind of thought but they did
find that will and it was
handwritten um they also discovered that
Roger had flown to duth Minnesota a
month prior to the murders and he was
asking he had gone there alone without
margerie even though I believe this was
the first time that he had ever met his
mother-in-law Elizabeth he had never met
her before but he flew to the house by
himself and he went there to ask her
her and the trustees of the estate for
$750,000 because they wanted to buy a
ranch him and
margorie um and then they were like no
and he was like okay well can we at
least have
500,000 because we have all these debts
and we're going to go to jail and again
the trustees said no so there was
that there was also and this is pretty
weird so remember I said that from
Elizabeth bedroom there was like that
Byzantine era coin yeah so they found
money yeah they they said it was worth a
[__] ton of money I don't remember how
much they said it was but they said 1700
years yeah it was like yeah it was like
an Ancient Ancient so it would have been
like super
expensive so they found
this envelope it was in their um cuz in
when the um margerie and Roger were
living in Colorado they lived in a motel
essentially because they didn't have a
lot of money
in their mail slot in the motel was this
envelope that was found now the envelope
was addressed to Mr Roger C Caldwell but
it looked like his handwriting and like
everybody at the hotel and everybody
like that said yeah that's his
handwriting so it's like he had mailed
it to himself kind of and it had that
coin in
it now the thing about it was that they
couldn't figure out they're like okay if
indeed Roger had sent had mailed this
coin to
himself they were like why would he do
that I mean it seemed like at their
theory was oh well he was sending it to
margorie as a signal that oh you know it
I did it you know what I mean but the
thing about it though was that it didn't
get there until after he got back so
they're like well what was the point of
that then like they still don't know
spoiler alert they still don't know why
um um now they did say that they found
his
fingerprint on the back of the envelope
okay and they did say that they thought
that it was his handwriting so it looked
like he had addressed it to himself like
he had sent himself this coin for
whatever reason and it was postmarked in
duth on the day of the murders which
like I said would have placed him in the
vicinity when the murders took place
when he was supposedly because he lived
in Colorado you know what I mean so that
was like a big thing his
trial the hair that they found at the
scene um was also similar to Rogers not
exactly because like I said this is the
70s so they didn't really have like the
forensic kind of stuff and I don't think
here's the thing they said that the
hairs that they found in velma's hand
like the nurse were
black um as far as I know Roger's hair
at the time even though he was only I
believe in his mid-40s I think his hair
was gray so I'm not really sure if it
was her own hair or I'm not really sure
like I wasn't real clear on all of that
but they did say that some hair they
found in the house at the scene or
whatever was similar to his similar
enough that it seemed kind of suspicious
um they also found the blood on the
pillow because they think that whether
he was the killer or not that he beat
the nurse to death on the stairs and
then went up and put his hand on the
pillow when he was smothering Elizabeth
so there was kind of a blood smear on
the pillow and that blood was the same
type as Rogers like I said this is 1977
so they couldn't do DNA it was just like
the same type and I believe it was type
O blood which is common I mean I have
type O blood you know what I mean not a
well planned murder yeah and uh I feel
like that messy in a way um that kind of
well he okay spoiler alert like he did
get convicted at first but later on when
he was exonerated and and the way that
the def his defense attorney like laid
it the defense attorney laid it out um
it did sound like kind of dumb like if
somebody was really doing this for and
they didn't want to get caught like they
would have gone about it in a much
different way so that's the only thing
that makes me think that maybe he didn't
do it but I still think he so the
defense was it was a random dude that
came in I will say too that Roger was a
notorious drunk right he might have been
drunk when he didn't and well yeah I I
he kind of admitted that yeah um so
I mean he was drunk like all the time so
it's
possible that he could have you know
taken a few nips to like build up his
courage to do the murder turned out the
nurse was there he had to kill her and
then yeah um so that's why he kind of
boted or he wasn't really thinking about
it clearly so it could have been that I
mean it could have been just that he was
kind of inated you know for those of you
that are listening to the show recorded
please give us a a damn super thanks
that's a a fixure that we have activated
where you can send us a uh basically a
super chat but it's not live ain't that
some [__] here comes Pooky hi Pooky so
I'm just plugging super tanks thank you
for plugging that
yeah um yeah tequila says good old mesh
Basher yeah that was the name of the
defense attorney mesh Basher that was
his last name yeah we'll get out a
little bit so yeah so not only did they
find this envelope that Roger called
well hey it's Pooky she pook's coming on
the show she's like no I don't want to
be on the show I don't want to be on the
show you took my you took my wrapping
paper away she's mad she's mad she she
went over there earlier cuz that's where
the wrapping paper look she's still
looking for it she's looking for the
it's not there no I put it away I took
it
away she was like looking and she
couldn't find it so she went over to the
Bookshelf and like pulled a bunch of
books out cuz she was upset smacked her
on her tail she's like what what it's
not there poy not there anymore she's
just going to sit there looking at it
sadly where's the paper Maybe paper will
come back if you guys know what we're
talking about in the last few shows she
was over there [__] smacking paper
was like Christmas paper like leaned
against the wall over there and she was
paper P I took it
away she's mad she's like looking at the
wall she's looking at the wall where the
paper should be where's the paper you
want me to put it back I know you do no
we're not putting it back you make back
because you make too much an noise
you'll make too much an noise yeah she's
like well I'm going to go pull some more
books out then that's how she's looking
bam oh
uhoh face to face to kiss him a kiss and
she's like
they're not they're not fighting I think
they're friends now yeah they're friends
now it seems like they're friends now
they're going sniffing each other's
faces I was kind of worried at first
because I thought they were kind of yeah
but they're pretty chill friends now
they're they're pretty
chill so uh so yeah so they have this
envelope with the coin in it and they
know that the coin came from Elizabeth's
bedroom uh you know the handwritings
seem to be Rogers there seem to be a
fingerprint on there that also matched
Rogers fingerprint is thumb print
actually um you know same blood type
similar hair blah blah also um when they
went into marjerie and Rogers hotel room
where they were living um after the
funeral they found a bunch of Jewelry in
there that looked suspiciously like the
jewelry that had been taken from the
Mansion now they asked Marjorie about
this and her excuse was oh well um you
know me and my mom just had a lot of the
same jewelry that's all it is this is
mine we didn't take that from there a
likely story so as I mentioned earlier
they did find the nurse's car later on
at the airport and found the keys in the
parking ticket uh in the garage so the
parking ticket had a time stamp on it of
6:35 a.m. which they said would have
given the killer ample time um to drive
from there to duth like cuz I think it
was 150
miles um also while they were looking
through the hotel room they found a
receipt from an air like from the gift
shop in the
airport and whoever the receipt belonged
to Apparently one of them had bought
like a garment bag on the same morning
as the murders and some of the two of
the people that worked in the gift shop
said they remembered somebody very much
like Roger buying the gift bag or the
garment bag and putting a wicker basket
inside of it which I thought was kind of
weird but okay they weren't entirely
sure that Roger was the dude but like
when they showed him the photos they're
like yeah that kind of looks like the
dude that came in and bought the garment
bag so at this point it's like evidence
it's like circumstantial evidence right
but they thought um you know the chief
prosecutor thought that there was enough
[__] to go on at this point now so they
arrested Roger two weeks after the
murders now at this point they don't
know because this has been such a
high-profile case because one of the
victims obviously was like this big
famous ays in uh the Del area so they're
like okay well we can't get a fair trial
so they had to move it to uh
brainer which you know several miles
away like how far away is brainer I
think I looked it up but I think it's
100 miles or 150 miles something like
that so they moved it like quite a
distance
away now I talked about the handprints
before like they found two handprints
and they were trying to say like the
prosecution I think was trying to say oh
this is the or the defense was trying to
say rather that these were like the real
killer but they found out later that
they belonged to one of the cops and
another nurse that like worked in the
house so obviously that wasn't it um
another weird thing that happened was
that one of the Jers had to be
dismissed because she had gotten a
letter which was
unsigned offering her
$110,000 for a guilty
verdict um so I thought that was kind of
interesting they never did figure out
who sent the letter I have my suspicions
but um
but they're like okay well that juror
obviously like has been compromised so
they had to like get rid of them and get
another one so there was that um now
some of the problems were even though
they had like kind of all the
circumstantial evidence nobody had
apparently seen Roger in duth Minnesota
that
day and because this was
1977 it's not like nowadays where if you
take an airplane flight somewhere like
your name is on the passenger list
obviously they kind of had that back
then but I don't think it was like super
stringent so there were only two
particular flights that you know
hypothetically if the killer had flown
from Colorado to duth Minnesota on this
particular day there were only two
particular flights he could have taken
and his name was not on either one of
them um even though he could have used
an alias because I don't think you had
to even produce ID to get on a [__]
plane back then which is crazy um it
wasn't that crazy in the world well
that's why well yeah but that's why
there were so many like airplane
bombings and [__] back then there
weren't there wasn't a computer system
so you couldn't track anything anyway
yeah you couldn't track anything so it's
just kind of like so he might have used
a pseudonym that's possible um but
they're not real sure because they
accounted for most of the passengers
that were on there that day but so I
don't know so they just didn't have any
record of him flying on either one of
those flights is what I'm
saying so there was that um and as I
said there's really no motive for Roger
to have mailed the coin to himself if
that was what he had done um he got back
to Colorado before it got there because
the only thing they could think of was
like well he was sending it to margorie
like as a signal that he had done the
deed but he's like well it you know he
was going to get back before the coin
got back so that's really dumb because
he would have just got back and said hey
I did it you know what I mean so it just
seemed really strange like why that
would have happen happened so there was
that um and the fact that that was so
weird was one of the main things that
his defense used to basically say that
he had been set up they didn't really
come out and say exactly like who it was
they thought had set him up they kind of
went into that later when margerie went
on trial but um they did kind of say
that maybe someone was trying to frame
him for the murders you know what I mean
they didn't want to come out and say
like who they thought it was but they're
like cuz it just seemed
really like a weird thing to do if you
were trying to um you know kind of get
away with the murder like why would you
and and the thing about it too is that
the envelope was from like the hotel you
know what I mean it was like the hotel
that he was living in like the
stationary so they're like that so that
would be really really stupid if you did
that I mean I'm not saying that he
wasn't stupid maybe he was but they just
couldn't think of any reason why he
would do that so you
know um
also there was kind of a thing where um
the car that the killer had stolen from
the house which belonged to Velma the
nurse that was murdered they said that
the weird thing was that if you were
trying to hide the car again they're
like where it was parked was like right
by the entrance like it wasn't like it
was way back in the lot or anything like
that like it was right by the entrance
like the keys and parking Lo were right
there in the garbage can like they found
it pretty easily so it's like if you
were trying to like get away with murder
that seems like you would try to hide it
better than that that's what the defense
was
saying also there was a thing where
their whole thing was the point of entry
was this window in the billiard room and
they thought that whoever the killer was
had busted the window open like maybe
with a rock or something like that and
then had reached in and like pulled the
latch and opened the window so they were
mostly able to show that Roger's arm was
too big to have fit through the hole and
or his arm was too short for him to have
been able to reach the latch you know
what I mean like if he like reached
through the hole because they had one of
the cops do it they set up a mockup like
in the courtroom the same size as the
hole and they had one of the cops whose
arm was slightly smaller I believe than
Rogers and he like tried to reach
through and he couldn't like he couldn't
reach the latch so they were trying to
use that to say that Roger couldn't
possibly have done it because his arm
would fit through the hole that they
found so there was that now um so Roger
did not testify at his own
trial uh the trial went on for about
eight weeks um and the jury deliberated
for two and a half days and then came
back and found him guilty of both
murders so he got two consecutive life
terms in prison a minimum of 35 years
behind bars but he wouldn't end up
serving much of that as it
happened now because he got
convicted um the prosecutors were like
well [__] man if this was the case we're
sure that margerie was the brains behind
this because he wouldn't have just gone
there randomly and like killed that old
lady for no reason so it's like margerie
must have been the one to send him there
and did it so we're going to go after
her so they decided they were going to
go after margorie as The
Mastermind now so they're kind of going
after her like conspiracy to commit
murder which is notoriously easier to
prove I guess than actual murder because
you don't have to have necessarily been
there you just have to have been proved
to like planned it you know what I mean
now um and the thing about it was that
everybody knew that she hadn't been
there because everybody like a bunch of
people had seen her in Colorado like
when the crimes took place but they all
thought she sent Roger there to do it it
and that was that whole $2.5 million
will thing like that that was they
considered that like a payment you know
what I
mean so margerie gets the attorney uh
which tequil mentioned before Ron mesh
Basher mesh Basher who was apparently
one of the best lawyers in the midwest
because she had the well I was going to
say she had the money she didn't exactly
have the money but she sure spent it
like she had it but he was like the top
lawyer and for good reason you know I
mean um it's in the book they go a long
way like toward what his defense was and
it's like yeah I probably would have let
her off too well I don't know I wasn't
there but you know what I
mean so the thing about it was that he
had the transcript from Rogers trial so
he pretty much knew like how the
prosecution was going to come out them
so he could really kind of like prepare
a lot better um so yeah they actually
had to move her trial too because the
case was so high-profile so they moved
that to Hastings
now one of the major things that
happened during margery's trial was that
mesh Basher was able to find not just
one but two forensic experts who were
willing to come on the stand and say
that the fingerprint on that envelope
was not Rogers like and they were just
like we don't even know why the original
Dude said that because it's obviously
not his and because the fingerprint on
the envelope was one of the main pieces
of forensic evidence that was like a
huge deal that he was able to find two
other dudes who were able to come
forward and say like we looked at it and
it's obviously not his it's like a
completely different it's a completely
different
dude um now at this point like
also the defense attorney CU I kind of
feel like what they were trying to get
at because she was being charged with
conspiracy to commit murder basically
they didn't have to disprove that Roger
had committed the murder I mean Roger
could have still committed the murder
that was fine they just wanted to prove
that she didn't know [__] about it that
he like acted on his own volition that
was fine or or he didn't do it and it
was just like a random ass person you
know what I mean so it didn't matter if
Roger had committed the crime as long as
like they were just trying to prove that
she didn't know anything about it and
she didn't plan it so there was a thing
they had somebody come
forward um in Colorado
and then there was a waitress in
Colorado even though she didn't say [__]
at the time of Rogers trial two years
prior they were actually able to find
her and she's like oh I saw Roger in
Colorado like on the day of the murder
right and there was no way that he could
have gone to Minnesota so there was that
like I said seemed a little fishy
because she didn't say anything about it
back then but whatever but they did get
her to say that for marjorie's trial now
the thing about it so
margorie um she didn't end up taking the
stand in her own defense but they said
it was kind of like I don't know if I'd
go so far as to say like a circus but
she was for sure trying to push like the
harmless Grandma angle cuz she was
about I mean she wasn't that old at this
point I think she was only in her 40s
but she was kind of like she would like
sit at the table and do her
knitting um she always had like a book
that she was reading it's like she was
always kind of like smiling at the
jurors and everything like that um when
it was Ron mesh Beth Bashers that's her
defense attorney when it was his
birthday like she baked him a cake and
like brought it into the courtroom so
she was very clearly trying
to give everybody a show it's just like
look I'm just like a harmless like
lovely person I would never do anything
like that you know what I mean which
seems kind of like transparent but
whatever um but she but you know she was
obviously trying to make it look like
she couldn't have done anything like
this like they were accusing her of now
at first cuz margerie man uh she [__]
loved to talk and she wanted to
testify but her attorneys strongly
advised against it because they thought
you know they knew her really well and
they were like she's the kind of person
that's going to get on the stand and
just say all kind of crazy [__] and
we're not going to be able to like
control her or get her to like stick to
our narrative so we just would rather
not step into that Minefield pretty much
so they're just like we would really
advise you not to testify on your own
behalf um she was kind of bummed about
it and I guess they had like a big
argument but in the end uh the attorneys
did win they were just like yeah we
don't want you to testify please don't
um but so the defense was basically
trying to put forward um this whole
thing that they had been framed
essentially um um I believe they brought
out at margery's trial I don't think
they brought this up at Roger's trial
but I think at margery's trial they
insinuated that the person possibly
responsible for the frame up was Thomas
conden who was Elizabeth's nephew and it
was also one of the trustees of the
estate so he was one of the people that
you know essentially cut Marjorie off
from the money because she was spending
all of it so they defense insinuated
that it was Thomas conden and perhaps a
kind of Shifty private investigator that
he had hired that were kind of um
gunning to uh set Roger and possibly
margorie up for the crime the argument
was that look the whole family hates
margorie they know that she's in a lot
of financial trouble and that she's
always asking for money and they know
what she's like so I guess they were
kind of like saying that it's like okay
well the the family justar is like a
scapegoat or like a Psy because she had
said stuff about getting all this money
after her mom died and so they wanted to
set her up because they pointed out the
defense was pointing out especially the
stuff about like the coin being like the
Roger mailed to himself and all this
other kind of stuff they're just like
why would anybody do that it's just like
see and why would they have left like if
they didn't want to get caught why would
they have left all the jewelry that they
supposedly stole from Elizabeth's room
like why would it just be laying out in
their hotel room for everybody to find
like and everybody to see and all this
other kind of stuff it's like why would
they have just left this evidence laying
around like it seemed more like a setup
that's what they were kind of trying to
make it seem like and it seems kind of
reasonable but I don't know if I believe
that though I think they were maybe
Roger was just an idiot but you know who
who knows but that's what they were
trying to
argue so the thing about it was that all
of the [__] that they did and like I
said they in the book Glen Sheen's
daughter they go into a long thing about
what um mesh Basher said at
her um
trial and the way that he laid it out
did kind of sound reasonable you know
what I mean so I could see how jurors
would be like yeah maybe maybe they
didn't do that [__] you know what I mean
so I could you know he was a really good
defense attorney that's why she hired
him he was like one one of the best in
the midwest if not the country at the
time so the way he laid it out did make
it sound like there was reasonable doubt
that there maybe had been a frame up of
some kind or you know there was or even
if Roger had done it like there was no
way she would have known about it or
anything like that because they argued
that you know Roger was a drunk which
was true and that he was abusive to her
which was also true and that she was
used to lying because she didn't want
people to know he was a drunk because
she was embarrassed of him which is also
true so they leaned hard on that so they
kind of like made her seem like a victim
where it's like you know she didn't know
where he like he would would go off to
bars and get [__] up he would go off
on a toot that's what he called it and
um you know and he would just vanish for
a day or two at a time and she didn't
know what the [__] he was doing but she
would like make excuses for him all the
time so they leaned hard into that which
like I said was somewhat true so they
kind of used that to make her seem more
like a victim you know what I'm saying
which I don't think was necessarily the
case but it worked uh you know she did
end up getting
acquitted not only did she get acquitted
but she actually and even the jurors
came up to her afterward and like hugged
her and stuff like yay congratulations
and I think she even went out to dinner
with her lawyer and some of the jurs
like afterward because they thought she
was so awesome like she was just this
little lady that knitted in the
courtroom and brought cakes and [__]
like that like I said she was leaning
very hard into that motherly
grandmotherly kind of image and it
totally worked so she got
acquitted now after she got acquitted um
Rogers attorneys were like well because
they introduced all of this new evidence
that they didn't have available at
Rogers trial including the fingerprint
thing where they had these experts
saying that was absolutely not Roger's
fingerprint on the envelope which was
one of the main pieces of forensic
evidence they're like well then we need
to get Roger a new trial also because
that's some [__] right there so they
filed an
appeal now um so the thing about it so
the
appeal kind of goes ahead and it takes a
while
so he goes to prison I think it was in
early 1978 I believe he was put in
prison so the appeal process kind of
comes out they're like all right we're
going to Grant him a second trial you
know given all of the new stuff that
came out at margery's trial so they gave
him a new trial in August of
1982 So eventually he
got he got like it was appealed like his
conviction was
overturned um and he got released now he
had spent a little little more than five
years in prison at this point so he got
out even though he'd been convicted of a
double murder and five is a long time I
mean five is a long time but yeah
guarantee if you [__] did one one
year in prison you would think that was
a a life
time yeah I
mean you know and he looked like kind of
in bad shape so yeah so they basically
so they overturned his conviction what
happened though was I think okay so what
they wanted to do they wanted to do a
second Tri like they wanted to retry it
but they were afraid that he would get
convicted again and then go back to
prison cuz he was free now and he had
like moved back to Pennsylvania that's
where he was from and so what they had
him do was that because they're like
this is going to be really expensive and
it's like look he's already been in jail
and blahy blah so they proposed a plea
bargain now at first the first one they
offered him they said tell you what if
you confess to the double murder then
we'll just give you another year in
prison and then you'll be out and he was
like nah he didn't want to do that cuz
he'd already like I said moved back to
Pennsylvania at this point and he's just
like I want to like hold out for a
better deal and eventually they gave him
a better deal they basically said you go
in front of a judge and confess to those
murders and you're free like it's time
served essentially is what they said
because he'd already been in jail for
five plus
years so I mean he's not that stupid so
he was like okay even though it's going
to be on your record like forever like
that you committed a double murder but
he doesn't want to spend any more time
in jail right so I mean that's kind of
understandable like I don't know if he
did it or not I kind of suspect he
probably did but so there's that so yeah
that's what he did so he goes in front
of a judge and he tells them here's the
thing I read in the book there is a
transcript of what he said at his
confession
and even though he kind of said oh I was
kind of drunk and I don't really
remember all the details which very well
might have been the case because he was
kind of always
drunk but the way that he talked about
it kind of makes me feel like he did it
but some of the stuff that he said was
inconsistent to the facts of the case
too so I'm kind of torn on it because
some of the [__] he said I was like wow
that sounds like super specific for
somebody who didn't do it you know what
I mean like the way he described it
because you have to think that the time
that allegedly if he went there and
killed those two women this was only the
second time he'd ever been to this house
he'd been to the house the first time
like a couple months prior to talk to
Elizabeth about borrowing all that money
but he didn't like go anywhere in the
house he just basically went in the
front in the library like where he met
with her and she said no you can't have
any money and he didn't like look around
the house or nothing so he'd only been
there like One Time by himself so this
would have only been the second time
that he was there and the way that he
talked about it I don't know it kind of
made me feel like he probably did it but
then like some of the [__] he said was
not consistent like somebody mentions
only five years for a double murder yeah
was he really convicted of a double
murder though yes and he only got five
years well no he got two life sentences
okay okay yeah but be he got two life
sentences but a couple like when
Marjorie was tried she acquitted yeah
and the case changed and some and the um
the evidence that came out at her trial
cuz she was like kind of exonerated him
or that's they thought they would
overturn it because like I said it was
the fingerprint evidence mostly because
that was kind of like the main thing
that clears that up right but I still
kind of think do not for one that you
can kill two people in the United States
only get five years for it no unless you
have a [__] ton of money then you
probably won't get any and then there's
a whole bunch of there's a whole bunch
of coating corroborating evidence that
maybe it was
self-defense then maybe but no under
normal circumstances no you'll never do
it no like I said the only reason he but
yeah his sentence was two life sentences
because it was a double murder and it
would you know with pre-planning
obviously um but because of the stuff
that came out at her trial later on most
like five years later they were kind of
like oh we can probably get Roger off
now too because all this new [__] came
out most most states carry a life
sentence for
murder now manslaughter that's a
different circumstance manslaughter is a
homicide that would normally be a murder
but it's uh but the homicide was
conducted
under situations where there was um
enough
provocation to deny the
defendant calm reasoning and cool
reflection that type of deal in other
words it was an aggravated thing where
people were [__] with it that ended
could end up being a
manslaughter and just in general knowing
how the criminal justice system is on
average a manslaughter could be anywhere
from zero to 40
years
so that's still something that's up in
the air you could you could commit a
Mass Slaughter and effectively get a
life sentence or you could commit a
manslaughter and if the judge thinks you
had a reason for doing what you're
doing he could give you
probation and that's not normally what
happens though what normally happens is
you get four or five
years um now some foreigners might
foreign to the American scene well how
can you get four years for kill you got
people in the United States that want to
kill each other you got two men that are
fighting trying to kill one another one
survives it what do you do with
them wasn't quite self-defense but they
had he not done what he done he would
have
died it would be a Mass
Slaughter basically
dueling and you could get a couple years
for that yeah but
that's that's that's kind of for the
American situation that's about right
yeah two guys trying to kill each other
and then the one dude that
survives yeah you give him a couple
years so he doesn't do it again but you
don't have to [__] throw that guy
away had he not done what he done he
would have died you know he didn't have
a choice once the fighting started they
were both trying to kill each other yeah
so you know well that's why they give
that's why we have trials and [__] like
that because it's kind of like there's
right circumstances there's
circumstances to you know what I mean
right everything's different we got we
got to hear everybody yeah and that is
not necessarily the case in Europe in
Europe it's going to be very different
from that IA would think but the United
States not really I don't know is it not
that I ever saw it's pretty it's pretty
similar it's about similar okay well our
laws came from English laws for
sure law so their their laws are very
very similar
okay um tequil says uh to be honest the
staircase is pretty much a straight shot
up from the basement and one right turn
to Elizabeth's room yeah I think it was
just kind of like from what I saw in the
picture like I said it's kind of hard to
tell but it looked like a landing that
had like a window was it a window or it
was just like a bench it looked like a
window seat I think that's what kind of
we unless that's not what that picture
was but that's what I saw Tammy said his
wife probably gave him the lay of the
house that's kind of what I was thinking
because it's like you know allegedly
allegedly um she's still alive as far as
I know he's dead but um I do kind of
feel like these two [__] heels probably
plan this and like I said I think she
sent him out there to do that and said
hey this is where her room is and blah
blah I don't think that they knew that
the nurse was going to be there
necessarily I don't think they were
planning to kill the nurse but that
doesn't make it any better let me
address Danny Danny's talking about my
guns and my [__] calf muscles and
[__] uh [__] no uh you go on my uh
Instagram I got videos of my Cavs
because of the army and everything and
me working out and [__] being on gear
[__] no my calf muscles are ifbb pro
level calf muscles my calves look like
it's a couple of [__] rotisserie
chickens on the back of my legs I got
big ass calves with V's cut in them so
I'm not like this [__] dude that
plays [__] who's that actor that
plays [__] Thor what's that guy's
name blond haired guy um the
[__] skipping leg day I've seen
his legs he got [__] skinny ass no I
got [__] good legs bro my legs are
better than my
arms you do have nice you do have nice
calves [__] my calvs with the [__] man
look like [__] chickens back
there it's mostly
genetics but you work yeah I mean you do
leg stuff but you mostly do arms mostly
do arms because my arms were actually
behind my legs yeah but being in the
Infantry Ruck sacks and go up and down
Korea my whole life and just the [__]
that I did as soon as I started [__]
going back into training and getting
involved in test and gear and [__] like
that my [__] calves just blew
up I look back down on them and they're
better than they ever ever were when I
was [__] in my early 20s I got nice
legs he's got nice legs got a nice dick
too I got that [__] you do yeah that
shit's on I got it [__] recorded man
go look at you also have a nice butt
yeah
yeah you do have a nice deck it's nice
you should see how Jen's looking hold on
let me get this camera Jen is looking so
[__] cute she look how cute this [__]
is looking look at that the little feet
well I can't sit
chair yeah Jen's looking so I was I was
sitting sit up straight J I was sitting
cross-legged but you could see my put
your arms up yeah look at that [__]
would you stop okay all right like all
right yeah no Jen Jen Jen's been in
training and she looks [__] great
right now about some [__] here [__]
she looks better now than she looked
even in her [__] 30s when when I
first met her yeah I think I think I was
38 when I met 38 when we met yeah I
think so yeah you look [__] right
around she's so much hotter then you're
so much hotter than you were well thank
you yeah you are you're gorgeous I try a
you're so nice you say nice things
sometimes why do you think we're
throwing down all the
time we're in our 50s
now and [__] you know we just did the
right things
yeah you don't have to you don't have to
grow old gracefully you can just be no
you can fight it yeah that's what I'm
doing [__] fight that [__] Zach says
this whole case kind of gives me Dolores
Clayborn vibes oh yeah clor who was that
that was a Stephen King novel okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah they made it oh I don't
think we've ever reviewed that movie
that was a good movie I love that book
yeah the movie was actually really
decent it had Kathy Bates in it and um
and um what's her name I can see her
face yeah I can't think of it I'll think
of it in a second but yeah so but yeah
so he did get convicted of two life
sentences but because of the evidence
that came out so he basically said yeah
I totally did that [__] now he
said like I said the statement that he
gave it was odd because it was like like
I said in some ways it was kind of super
specific but also vague enough that some
of it didn't really line up with what
really happened so I'm kind of torn I
don't really like I do still think he
did it probably but I don't know some of
the [__] that he said like kind of made
me question that he basically said yeah
did this that and the other thing like
he waited in the
cemetery um for a while behind the house
while he was waiting for everybody to go
to bed like he was waiting for all the
lights to go out and everything like
that and he was um drinking quite a bit
when he was in the cemetery like he was
trying to get his courage up that's what
he said and then he broke in and did the
[__] now he said when they asked him
about um you know why' you take that
coin and all that other stuff he
basically just said he didn't remember
and he also said that he didn't
remember
um taking the flight from Colorado to
Minnesota he didn't
remember taking any of the jewelry he
didn't remember any of that that's what
he said but I don't know I I don't know
if he was drunk and he really didn't
remember or he was just or he didn't do
it and he was just making the story up
so he didn't have to be in prison
anymore so he was just kind of like I
don't know I don't remember remember any
of the details cuz he wasn't there or I
don't know I don't I don't know what the
deal
was but his story was that he's like
well I just meant to rob the place I
didn't mean to kill anybody I didn't go
there insistent and you know meaning to
kill anybody and he's just like and
that's why I didn't really have a
getaway plan because his quote was I
didn't have any plan this was the most
amateurish slip sha thing now that I've
had years to ponder it and I'm like well
yeah it was
um but he says he wasn't really thinking
clearly that's what he says now even
though at this point
margorie had been put on trial for
conspiracy to commit murder and she had
been acquitted so because of Double
Jeopardy she could not be tried again um
so it wouldn't have really hurt anything
even if um even if Roger said now yeah
that [__] like put me up to it or
whatever but he would not he would not
um he just said she didn't have anything
to do with it it um you know she's in
the clear so there was
that now so he got out of prison however
his life was uh not great after that he
moved back to Pennsylvania where he was
from and he was an alcoholic as I
mentioned uh he got very very very fat
um he went on
welfare uh he lived above a bar which he
took a lot of advantage of and basically
got
$186 a month like welfare and that was
it and just like War Clos much $186
that's nothing well yeah that's that's
welfare this was uh in
the80s yeah6 wouldn't pay [__] for even
for [__] even in the even the even in
the 80s no well like I said people talk
about people living high on the hog and
Welfare I'm like uh no they're not they
don't they don't get [__] even nowadays
you don't but um but yeah I mean like
I've got unemployment I've got [__] like
that it's it's nothing my family got
welfare it's nothing so he got that you
know just got closed from thrift store
so he wasn't uh doing
great now at one point he actually
contacted the conden
family and said hey if you guys give me
a lot of money I have evidence that
other people were involved in the murder
you know what I mean so the family is
like okay well we're kind of interested
we'll give you
$50,000 but we have to have proof that
the evidence you're talking like what is
the evidence that you're talking about
we have to have proof that it's
something um and he's like no no no um
I'll give it to you later except give me
$100,000 at which point the family was
like no bro and they just like cut him
off and didn't talk to him
anymore now in
Roger committed suicide he actually slit
his wrists with a steak knife steak
Knife yeah that's
serrated um I don't know if it was a
serrated one or if it was just like a
smooth edge one okay no they're usually
Ser I mean I know they are but I think
they specifically said that it was like
a smooth one okay uh he was at this
stage 54 years old only nine people
showed up at his
funeral uh one of whom was a the author
of the book of the person that or the
person that wrote this book yeah um they
found a suicide note actually they found
three suici side notes uh the dude was
drunk as [__] uh they did know that his
blood alcohol level was super high when
he did it yeah um two of the suicide
notes were illegible they were just like
scrawled whatever um the third one he
said he I didn't kill those girls or to
my knowledge ever harm a soul in my
life problem with that though was that
when he was he'd been living in lro prob
Pennsylvania and he lived with his
girlfriend I don't know what her name
was but a few days before he killed
himself he had beaten the absolute [__]
out of her and she was in the hospital
she was
bad so his whole thing and his suicide
note he never harmed a soul in his life
eh not so much not so much he beat the
crap out of his girlfriend and honestly
a lot of the stuff I wouldn't really
necessarily trust anything marjerie said
but um cuz she seems like a compulsive
liar but some of the children who knew
Roger said that he was an abusive drunk
like that he smacked her around too like
when he was [__] up so there could be
that but yeah he totally um beat his
girlfriend bad enough that she had to go
to the hospital a couple of days before
he killed himself but then like said
that he never hurt anybody so you know
there's that um great
now so
margerie even though
allegedly she had talked Roger into
killing her mom that's what everybody
thinks like I said I don't it wasn't
proven I don't know it does seem like
that's what happened but I don't know
but even that's the story so even though
everybody thinks that um she apparently
once he had done that if indeed he did
it she evidently had no more use for him
um like I said she does really come
across like a classic sociopath in this
sense that people are just objects to be
used for a particular goal and then
discarded uh she seems to have done that
multiple times in her life so she
visited him one time when he was in
prison for all those five
years now listen to this [__] so in
1981 um before he got before Roger got
out of prison she married again now this
guy was named Wally haen she married him
in North Dakota now it turns out that
she had not legally divorced Roger
first so there were bigamy charges filed
against her in North Dakota but because
bigamy is not seen as that big of a deal
it's not you can't extradite someone to
another state for that um they're
basically like well we can't bring her
to another state like to you know
convict her for that you know she just
can't go back to North Dakota again back
in the old days bigab was
widespread there wasn't just there
wasn't really divorce people just moved
around and married people they went that
happened a lot actually well because
like I said back in the old days they
didn't really have like computer
networks or anything like that if you
just moved to another state you could
just like come up with a new name and
and marry somebody else marry somebody
else you could marry somebody else under
your own name it wouldn't matter yeah no
one would find out cuz nobody could
people remarried all the time there
wasn't any way to cross check they
remarried why they were married a lot
yeah yeah well that happened here but
like I said this was the 80s uh and they
do have laws against that yeah but like
I said they don't it's not considered
like a huge like serious crime or
anything you know yeah which obviously
it probably shouldn't be I mean it's
kind of shitty but it's not really that
bad you're not hurting anybody you're
not killing people yeah you're not
physically hurting anybody or anything
like that so um but yeah so they're like
basically well you know she can't come
back to North Dak she comes back to
North Dakota like she might get caught
for it but other than that like why
would you want to go to North Dakota
anyway nobody knows so um so yeah now
here's the thing margorie had known w
and his wife Helen for many years since
the 1960s they actually met because both
of their kids were in ice skating
competitions because remember how I said
they were real big into that like back
in the
60s now the Haans Wally and Helen were
really some of the few friends that she
had that actually stuck with her all
this time and thought that she wasn't
guilty
right now it's suspected I don't know if
this is true or not it's suspected that
Wally and margerie may have begun an
affair back then I don't know if that's
the case um but that was kind of the
rumor going around
anyway now after Marjorie got acquitted
Helen Wally's wife got diagnosed with
Alzheimer's and then she got put in a
nursing
home
now a few days after Margery visited her
and was seen feeding her mashed bananas
from some baby food jars she went into a
coma H marjerie was the last person to
visit her 3 days after that Helen died
and not too long after that margorie and
Wall-E were seen together everywhere and
then they got
married now interestingly and this was
something that you don't see in a lot of
the breakdowns but this was in the book
margerie had told everybody at the
nursing home like the staff that she was
Helen's daughter which she obviously was
not Wally and Helen's actual daughter
they had three kids um whose name was
Nancy was like third of the third down
the list marjerie was the first person
to call if something went wrong with
Helen they were not related they were
just like friends and marjerie was
allegedly like [__] her husband from
going back to the 60s so there was that
you know so it was just like call
margerie first then call w-e then call
Nancy the actual daughter so there was
that and Nancy didn't find that out
until after her mom died like she went
to the nursing home and they're like
yeah it says that margorie was her
daughter and you were supposed to C
she's like what the [__] that's not she
like I'm their daughter what are you
talking about so there was that also
after Helen died Nancy the daughter said
that Wally her dad abruptly told her
with no Preamble like he just walks in
the house um I hated my wife for all 47
years of our marriage I only stayed
together for you guys like for the kids
and nany's
like Mom just died and why the [__] are
you telling me this right now like he's
free I'm free that is [__] up damn and
Nancy says she was 32 at the time her
dad told us is like look if you hated it
so much why like the kids are grown like
why didn't you leave you know he had no
other options but he wouldn't answer the
question like he just turned around and
left that [__] wasn't goodlook
anyway he couldn't didn't have any other
options that's what it was his arrogant
ass think about it yeah think about it
he was he he probably didn't like her
and got stuck with her but he couldn't
go anywhere either although I don't see
here's the thing as we'll go on with
this kind of [__] up [__] here but I
think that this was a case of margerie
almost like brainwashed because he was
pretty old at this point I think she was
like [__] with his mind she was good
at
that so yeah also Nancy the daughter she
also
reported she had she had an arrangement
with her dad to pick up her
four-year-old son whose name is Michael
up from daycare because she worked a lot
like she you know worked full-time and
had like she had a couple jobs so he
would pick her son up from
daycare one day he didn't do it like she
comes home she goes up to say good night
to her four-year-old and he's not there
and she goes down to her dad and is like
Hey where's Michael oh I didn't get him
like it was no big
what do you mean you didn't get him
Marge told me I didn't have to that's
what he said margerie told me I didn't
have to um and it turns out that the kid
because the kid had not been picked up
from daycare they had taken him into
State custody and put in a foster home
for the night because he needed
somewhere to go and Nancy had to go get
a court order to get him back just CU
her stupid [__] dad didn't pick him
up like he always had before because
Marge said I didn't have to that's what
he
said um also it turned out that the
money that Wally inherited after his
wife died that was supposed to be used
to pay like all the bills and stuff um
also went to
margerie uh so none of the bills had
been paid and Nancy ended up with
nothing she didn't get any of her
inheritance or anything um Wally was 23
years older than marjerie by the way uh
when they got married he was 72 and she
was 49 so there was that 72 and 49 but
what an age Gap yeah 72 that's old man
49 that's still kind of an old a young
woman yeah I mean just not that's
younger than me younger than you yeah so
but see here's the thing margerie even
though she was not particularly
good-look or anything like that she
seems to have had some weird kind of
like manipulative power and I mean this
dude was old you know he had you know
his wife was ill and he was taking care
of her and stuff like that but I kind of
feel like to some point like he might
have been I don't know he seemed like he
was like really manipula ated by her so
so they got married and not too long
after that a house that they had just
sold they had sold it to another family
but there was like a couple weeks where
they said oh we're going to fix it up
like before you guys take it over or
whatever but in the interim like the
night before they were supposed to like
when they got the keys and they were
supposed to move in the house
mysteriously burned
down now when the cops look into this
she had kind of had some rumors about
her you know unexplained fires like
happening around her a lot so
investigators kind of like when they
found out that she had been the owner of
the the previous owner of the house they
had like sold it to another couple um
they were like okay well maybe we want
to look into cuz her story was oh that
WALL-E who had been an electrician he
was retired had rewired the house and
maybe the wiring was bad or something
like that and that had caused it but
you know there there was a lot of [__]
going on that really looked like because
she still had keys to the house even
though she said she didn't it was this
whole
thing so um at this point they did
arrest her like they didn't have enough
money to arrest her for the arson like
insurance fraud you know what I mean um
and they did find evidence like she'd
never really been convicted convicted
but there were a lot of suspected fires
like a lot of people um suspected her of
like committing R sin now the same guy
who had defended her before old meesh
mesh fer uh he defended her again
however this time it did not work uh she
actually did get convicted this time of
arson and insurance fraud and got
sentenced to um a women's prison I think
her first sentence was two and a half
years I
believe so she got released about 20
months later so almost two years later
and then her and Wall-E moved to Arizona
like they moved to this tiny little town
called AO in Arizona in an
RV um about 40 mil from the Mexican
border
so margorie had told everybody that
Wall-E had cancer and that they wanted
to move really close to the Mexican
border because there were all these
drugs and treatments over there in
Mexico that weren't you know approved in
the United States yet that they thought
would help him so they were going back
and forth to Mexico all the
time while they were living in AO
Arizona there was a series I believe it
was just in one year 1990 of
43 suspicious
fires um which happened in empty houses
and garages in the
area now at first the cops thought it
was just kids going around burning [__]
down however one of the fires burned
down kind of a storage garage kind of
place where margerie and Wally kept
their uh RV their Airstream trailer so
they thought that was a little fishy
when they looked at into her background
also there was this so they started like
looking into her so Wally and margorie
had been having like a feud with their
nextdoor neighbor his name was Mark he
was 28 I believe he lived there with
like his younger brother or
something um they said oh he's like you
know messing with our dog whose name was
wolf and you know throwing garbage in
their yard [__] I don't know if that was
true I don't believe anything she says
now one night the neighbor Mar who was a
border patrol officer he had been a
border patrol officer for four
years and he heard something at his
window like scratching or like some kind
of like like someone was trying to pull
the window open because they were like
these casement windows that were they
were old houses they were like hard to
open and so he looks out and he sees
this rag that smelled like kerosene on
the window
cell now he saw what he thought was
marjorie's because it was his neighbor
he knew her and he thought he saw her
face like outside the window like with
her
dog and so he calls the cops so the cops
decide they're going to set a trap up
because there's all these fires happen
in this tiny tiny town so they're like
it's got to be the same person doing it
so around 1: in the morning the cops
come out and they see something and so
they come out and they chase the person
like they see somebody like lighting up
lighter in like the rag ignites right
and the and Mark and his brother saw it
inside to they tried to take pictures of
it but they didn't come out so um so the
cops like Chase the person down this
alley and they catch her and it's
Margery so she's trying to set her
neighbor's house on fire with the
neighbor still in it
what they lived like literally like
right next door and she was like in her
night gown and she was barefoot and
everything how old is she at this point
um I believe at this point yeah I think
she's in her 50s [__] crazy that's what
I'm telling you [__] 100% [__] yeah
she is nuts that's attempted murder
right there that's not our well yeah
yeah so um so yeah so they caught her
like
red-handed now she gets charged with
arson and they put her in jail at this
point so she's in jail for eight months
because they gave her bail but she
couldn't you know pay it because they're
broke at this point now
WALL-E who had been real sick and like a
wheelchair and [__] like while she was
out while she was in jail he got a lot
better
interestingly um kind of just going to
say munchow and by proxy kind of [__]
going on here is is a little bit of what
was going on
here um you know whereas before he
couldn't really walk or like anything
like that like now he's just like
tooling around town it's like they see
him sitting in restaurants like flirting
with waitresses like acting like a
normal dude I mean he's in his 70s but
they were like he was pretty spry he was
like in good shape but while she was
around he always seemed really sickly so
you know um and then so Marjorie gets
let out like pending
trial and then Wall-E started to decline
again and somebody who was kind of
acquainted with them said oh yeah she
gives him all these pills like to help
him sleep which I don't know exactly
what they were but it was
something now so when they put her on
trial for the
arson Wally testified on her behalf like
he just would not have it like he was
just sticking up for his wife and blah
blah I think he was totally brainwashed
at this
point so this was another kind of circus
atmosphere Wall-E gets brought into the
courtroom lying down on a gurnie because
he's say it's like oh I can't stand up I
have like all this stuff in my back and
blahy blah and he also brought their dog
with them which he said was his hearing
ear
dog okay
um his story was Marjorie couldn't have
set the fire because her arthritis and
her hands is so bad that she can't even
hold a normal siiz match so there's no
way because they you know when the
police caught her they found like a box
of Circle K matches in her pocket like
she you know what I mean and they're
like she can't even light those because
her um you know her arthritis is so bad
his story was that she had taken the dog
out for a walk in the middle of the
night um you know the dog dog often ran
to the neighbor's yard and somebody had
left this meat soaked rag hanging out
the window and then the dog grabbed it
and so margerie went back later to
return it to like put it back where she
found it a likely story also the whole
thing about Wally showing up in the
courtroom like on the gurnie some of the
jur that didn't really work because some
of the jurors like happened to look out
the window when he arrived and he got
out of the car just fine and then
marjerie was seen like helping him up on
the gurnie like pushing him into the
like they saw him walking around like
normal and so they're like yeah okay so
that seems a little
fishy so her [__] story they let her
testify on her own behalf which was
probably a mistake because she just went
on and on I don't know if she
necessarily I read some of her testimony
and it just she didn't really
incriminate herself but the way that she
went on and on um was kind of like I
don't know it just kind of I think
soured a lot of the jury against and
there was just like so much evidence
because they brought up there was a big
thing about you know cuz this was just
particularly for this you know the
neighbor like the attempted arson on the
neighbor's house and but they brought up
all these other things that she had been
suspected of committing in the past um
you know because they said that that was
admissible so I kind of feel like the
jury was like this [__] lady she's
insane now what happened so she got
convicted of that attempted arson and
then later they said hey if you plead
guilty or plead no contest to the other
arson charges then you know you'll get a
plead or whatever but she didn't get
like a really good deal now she did
plead no contest to the fire that had
destroyed the garage where she kept
their Airstream trailer which also
destroyed four other people's vehicles
that were also being stored there and it
turned out that she had also done two
more of the whole kerosene rag deal
on two other people in the neighborhood
who were both in her quilting group so I
don't really know if they just made her
mad I'm assuming because that's why I'm
assuming she did that to the neighbor
because it's like he just pissed them
off for some reason and she's just like
oh I'm going to get that [__]
I'm going to burn his [__] house down
but apparently that she had tried to do
the same thing with two other people in
the neighborhood that were in her
quilting group so because of that she
ended up getting 15 years a 15E sentence
which I mean you know it seems like a
lot but considering her history uh no
and considering the fact that she
probably like murdered a bunch of people
and didn't get caught um I'm I'm not mad
at it so um she was 60 years old at this
point when she got sentenced to the 15
years now here's another the story's not
over just wait so at her sentencing she
asked the judge can I please just have
24 more hours to make sure that my poor
sickly husband Wall-E is taken care of
like you know I need to make
arrangements for him because he you know
he's infirm and he won't get by without
me so the judge was kind of like
reluctant but he's like okay but you
know we're going to have all these cops
and [__] like that like watching you to
make sure you don't like run off you
know what I mean cuz they you know they
could have run to Mexico or whatever so
they followed her back to her house and
they had patrols coming back
by now one of the patrols that was
coming by and this was like 4 hours
before they were supposed to come in
like arrest her and like take her to
jail right one of the cops comes by and
happens to smell gas coming out of the
house so he knocks on the door margorie
answers and says oh everything's fine um
you know our pilot light just blew out
on the stove it's
cool couple hours later though she calls
some of her friends and relatives
to tell them that Wall-E her husband was
dead so the cops come she did now the
now he had been dead for several hours
um and apparently somebody she called
was like well why don't you call the
cops oh yeah probably I should do that
but this was like many hours later so
she calls the cops they come out now
they find that there's like a piece of
Hose which was you know she'd cut it off
the garden hose and it was kind of would
reach from the oven to the bedroom cuz
they had like an old gas yeah also they
found a bunch of prescription pills next
to the body and there was also a double
suicide note which is um I read it it's
in that book where she basically wrote
this note saying you know thanks for
everything you did it was addressed to
um their uh
attorney and basically saying thanks for
everything you did but we don't want
everybody thinking like we've been
framed up and we don't want everybody
thinking we did this and blah blah and
we're just going to go out together we
want to be buried in one big casket with
our dog I was like so they're going to
kill the dog like to bury these two [__]
heels [__] you guys you know what I mean
so it was that um but yeah so she wrote
this suicide so her story was that her
and Wall-E had a suicide packed and he
did it but then she was going to do it
too and then she chickened out so that
was kind of her defense that's what the
letter said cuz she basically in the
letter was like yeah we're we're we're
we're out of here like we're doing
that so the cops did not buy this uh as
you wouldn't so she got arrested um for
murder now they're kind of like trying
to call a grand jury and at this point
the prosecutors were not entirely sure
they could get a murder conviction
because they're like well had this been
a double suicide and she just backed out
of it um that might not be like people
might sympathize it's like I don't think
we can get a murder
conviction so they dropped the murder
charge even though they're pretty sure I
mean they're pretty sure that she
drugged
him and then did the whole hose thing so
it would look like they killed
themselves or Tred like that he tried to
kill himself cuz he couldn't live
without cuz she was supposed to go off
to prison the next day right so they
were trying to make it look like that um
so yeah so she didn't even get put on
trial for that they just dropped the
charges because they didn't think they'd
be able to prove it they're like oh well
that's some reasonable doubt they could
introduce like maybe it was a double
suicide Packa and like she just
chickened out you know what I mean what
are you going to
do um when they did the autopsy though
they did discover that Wally had not
died of the gas but had died of a drug
um and also fun fact the autopsy that
they did of him found absolutely no sign
of Cancer even though she had been
saying for years and years and years
that he had all kind of cancer and that
he had all kinds of health problems he
had no cancer zero cancer so the
speculation is that she had been doing
some munchow and by proxy [__] and she
was just like giving him all these drugs
and he didn't know what they were for
T says if you made a movie about it this
chick nobody would believe it that's
what I'm telling you this is f that's
why that's why tequila sent this book to
us I was reading this and I'm like no
[__] way this is insane it's insane
and the [__] is free I mean she's 91
now but she's free now crazy though yeah
I mean how many people is she killed at
this point allegedly five that's serial
killer [__] yeah and all the houses and
[__] she burned down had this happened
in the 1800s she would have killed
[__]
dozens because they had women like this
in the 1800s that there was no
bookkeeping and no computers you could
get away with anything but a chick like
this would have done a lot of damage in
the 1800s yeah she probably could have
killed a lot more people yeah cuz see
that's the thing it's like everybody I
kind of feel like for a long time like
all this was going on and like a lot of
people suspected her of [__] but she
just like they couldn't prove it yeah
like in this case it's like they were
pretty sure maybe
probably she killed Wall-E right I mean
he died of a drug overdose she probably
drugged him and she probably gave him a
lot because she'd been giving him a lot
over the years to make him seem sickly
so she could get sympathy and attention
and stuff like that um so she probably
gave him a [__] ton and then did the
whole gas thing probably after he was
already dead like to make it look like
they had this double suicide pack but
the thing about it was that the
prosecution was like well we can't prove
that that wasn't the case and they
didn't think it was worth
pursuing and they're like well she's
already going to prison for all the
arson and [__] anyway so I guess they
didn't really feel like it was worth it
she has all the [__] traits of female
Ser killer she does that's what I was
thinking it's like and and if she did
kill all the people that they suspected
because they think remember that she Not
only was I mean she didn't physically
kill her mom but they think that she
maybe manipulated Roger into killing her
mom also they think that she killed
Wally's first wife Helen Yeah by giving
her the they were feeding her stuff out
of baby food and then all of a sudden
like the next day she went into a coma
you know what I mean so there was that
and like I said she did try to maybe
kill her mom with the marmalade like
earlier so she was trying to poison
people so there was that so you know
seral killer so they dropped the charges
um so and like I said while he didn't
have any cancer even though she had
spent years saying that he had all this
cancer like I think she like three
different kind of cancer now so while
he's three kids um they're like we want
our Dad's Body back in Minnesota and to
be buried next to the mom like the first
wife that he supposedly said he hated
even though he's married to her for 47
years which I was like this even that
like even if that was true why would you
tell your daughter that that just seems
like so shitty I kind of feel like at
this point maybe I'm not exonerating him
um but I think margerie was maybe
drugging him and like playing with his
mind and [__] because he was kind of old
man at this
point now so yeah so the so the kids
wanted his body back
margerie who was in jail at this point
um wouldn't let them have it because
she's an [__] like that so they had
to go to court um and then finally they
the judge said okay well this is so
[__] up it's like well if you cremate
the body you can each have half the
ashes which is like okay I mean I guess
it's better than cutting the body in
half but whatever so margorie got the
other half of the ashes but the kids got
the half um and at this point after this
whole brewhaha that was when the kids
first started thinking that maybe
margorie had killed their mom too which
I kind of suspect she probably
did now so margorie she had a parole
Hearing in
2001 and two a W's kids were there and
she was trying to get early
release um she didn't show any remorse
for anything she had done um she's
basically talking about Will's or
Wally's children have been a thorn on my
side they've been [__] with me like
all this time she was always like
someone else was [__] with her like
someone was [__] up her life she
never took responsibility for anything
trying to make herself look like the
victim yeah that's and she did that a
lot um if like I said if you read the
book dead dead giveaway yeah this book
is like really good like and it goes a
lot into like her female serial killers
are always trying to make themselves
look like the V villain or excuse me the
victim U that goes all the way to the
one we had down here in [__] Florida
that was killing a lot of truck drivers
it was name [__] alen waros yeah oh
they were trying to rape me which maybe
some of them were well maybe the first
one was I think the first one it's
easier just to pay him and she was a
[__] lot lizard you know truckers
have money you know a lot lizard like
ien wasn't asking for a lot of money
better to just give her the $35 or the
$40 that she wanted they weren't trying
to rape her she just needed a she just
needed a justification to kill and Rob
them that's all it was I don't know I
suspect that maybe one did because it
does happen I mean you know uh well if
you're in that business that's going to
happen that's going to happen so I think
maybe that did happen to her once and
she used that as just a normal lot
lizard lot lizard woman isn't going to
[__] hold all the other truckers
responsible right for that one she did
though cuz she was mess yeah well she
needed to because she wanted to kill
dudes and get take their money yeah you
know but yeah so so yeah so she kind of
was just kind of like yeah they've been
[__] with me all this time blahy blah
um I should note that several of
margery's own children I believe five of
them I think that Rick her youngest and
Stephen um stood by her the whole entire
time and defended her but I think the
other five were like yeah [__] that
[__] um and we're basically would came
to the parole hearing and said please do
not let her out so you know that should
tell you something too um so 2004 uh she
was in prison for 10 years
and she got let
out now so after she was released in
2004 her lawyer his name was Edward
baling um he wanted to he approached uh
an author and wanted to write a book
about her um because she wanted some
money like he said basically she's broke
and she wants to like make some money
about it so the author was like um nah I
don't I don't think so it's like I kind
of know about this case and I know what
happens with people that go into
business with her so no thank you um and
then later it turned out that margorie
had accused that same Attorney Edward
balding of stealing her money while she
was in jail because even while she was
in jail her um she was still getting a
money from her uh from the estate you
know what I mean like she was getting a
stipend I think it was $4,800 a month
now she couldn't spend it obviously
because she was in jail but it was still
piling up in her account so she should
have had a lot of money when she got out
cuz she was in there for 10 years um but
and she was also getting Wally's pension
I believe so there should have been a
bunch of money in there but um she
basically said oh that lawyer took it
all and she sued him and she
won which is [__] crazy to me so he
got he got convicted of embezzling a
million dollars from her which I don't
know if he actually did that I wouldn't
believe it because she was just doing
that um and also here's like I said
story's not over yet so 3 years after
she got out
2007 she um makes friends with an old
man named Roger samis at an assisted
living home and she said hey old man
I'll help you out with your uh finances
yeah not surprisingly he died not long
after that and and then she kept writing
checks to herself with his signature on
them yeah like you do she had control
over his bank account yeah so they tried
that old man to get that privilege sure
I don't know she's done that's what I
mean see I don't get why BEC and
especially when the C when I read all
the stuff about Wally Hagen like yeah
what the [__] was she doing to that dude
to make because his kids said that he
completely cut them off and he was not
like that before they're like he just
became a completely different person
like after he married her and they
couldn't figure it out they're like they
didn't know like what she did to him
they didn't know if she was keeping him
drugs or what the [__] filled and full
of a bunch of
poison yeah she probably was just real
persuasive and she's like oh those kids
they're just trying to because he would
say [__] later on like um he didn't
leave his kids any money in his will
like he left it all to her and in his
will I think or you know something that
he said like right before he died he was
basically like those kids they've just
been draining me dry which and his kids
were like what the [__] we don't even
like we didn't know what he was talking
about like we never took any of his
money to money saying she did and so
they think that she turned him against
them by basically saying oh they're just
a bunch of vultures and they're trying
so she was real good at that Tak his
money saying that it was them taking the
money yeah I think that's probably what
she was doing so she had him completely
[__] and he wasn't all mentally there
yeah and I that's what it was he was
older and she probably had him on some
weird ass drugs and [__] like that too
yeah so um so yeah so this old man dies
and she's like cashing in money like on
his name the cops couldn't figure out
the cause of death because margerie had
hit power of attorney on this dude and
had him cremated before they could do
anything so she actually did get
arrested and she got charged with uh
fraud and forgery for faking his
signature but she just got Pro
probation now 3 years after that uh she
went and tried to get out of the
probation so she could go to an assisted
living facility but the judge said uh
no so as far as I know now margorie
would be 91 years old as far as I know
she's still alive I couldn't find her
obituary I did find the obituary of her
sister Jennifer who died a few years ago
um but as far as I know marjerie is
still alive and is probably still living
in Tucson Arizona uh probably still
burning [__] down I'd imagine cuz she
can still do that when you're old at 91
that [__] is sleeping most of the time
I hope so Jesus Christ all the [__] she
did holy crap she just like ruined so
many people's lives I can't imagine um
weirdly and I didn't I couldn't find
anything about this but they put um in
the back of this book there's like a
little epilog and there's like a um
article from the Minneapolis Star
Tribune and this is so weird so in
1999 Christy Caldwell O'Neal who was the
daughter of Roger Caldwell who if you'll
remember was uh marjorie's second
husband who was convicted and exonerated
of killing her adopted mom so his
daughter may have
allegedly suffocated her own mother
Roger's ex-wife who he was married to
before margorie with a pillow just like
Roger had allegedly done to
Elizabeth and then
christe kept her mom who was 65 in the
house for two weeks buried beneath a
bunch of salt in a cardboard coffin in
the basement H and once they found the
body like once the cops found the
body um Christy was found dead in her
car Apparently after having committed
suicide and that was Roger Caldwell's
daughter isn't that [__] weird yeah
holy crap so yeah so honestly so like I
said the family um in the trust like
after Elizabeth died uh the Glen Sheen
Mansion was donated to the University of
Minnesota duth um I believe there was
kind of like a period where you know her
relatives and or her uh you know
descendants and stuff could live in the
house at their discretion or whatever
but they after a time they um you know
donated it so people could come and tore
it um so two years after the murder they
actually opened it for public uh tours
and things like that but as I said they
don't usually talk about the murder on
the tour unless you specifically ask
them about it because they don't really
want to focus on that so that was that
[__] wasn't that [__] crazy that's
interesting that [__] [__] man yeah
thank you to KPS for sending this to us
this I got super into this I was just I
was reading all kind of [__] I'm like oh
my God I can't [__] believe this lady
if any of y'all have any weird cases you
want us to talk about you can send us
the books or the information or at least
a [__] um a link to you know uh some
kind of case that Jen can research and
we'll we'll do a show on it we'll talk
about it but uh yeah this is the
interesting one because you don't hear a
lot about because I feel like this woman
yeah I guess you don't hear a lot about
it because she was never convicted of
murder but had she been convicted of all
the Murder She was suspected of she
would for sure be a serial killer this
is a serial killer case I mean she's
very serial killer she fits the profile
of big time Big Time right um she even
has the whole arson thing arson
poisoning uh manipul manipulation it's a
long-term low simmer that they do it's
just like something out of the [__]
1800s that's what it kind of reminded me
of it reminded me of somebody like Bel
gunnis or somebody like that well I mean
Bel gunnis she was a lot more upfront
with the [__] she would just hit you in
the head with a shovel and take all your
stuff and just bury you in but this was
a very very common phenomenon in the
1800s it's yeah it was but it kind of
tapered off in in and U more modern
times 1800s 1900s you didn't hear this
kind of [__] died off but she's like a
she's like a blast from the
past and it's like as it's weird to me
because as blatant as the [__] that she
was doing was it seems like they could
never really pin anything on her I mean
they didn't really get her until they
got her for arson and she was like 60
years old at that point yeah think of
all the [__] that she had probably done
up to then had she been alive today she
would have been doing something like
Munch house and by proxy yeah she seemed
to like give me she gave me that Vibe
too because especially with all the [__]
about I think she was keeping Wally sick
all that time and telling everybody he
had cancer when he didn't yeah mun house
on by proxy and the thing and she also
said she would also kind of
exaggerate um well she said that her son
was it Rick or Steven I think it was
Ricky um said that he had real bad
asthma now he said that he did and like
he couldn't do stuff but I think she was
exaggerating like how bad his health was
you know what I mean like so she was one
of those people that's just like oh my
God he's [__] dying when maybe it
wasn't really that bad so she seemed
very attention seeking there was that
how long was the show uh it's 10:30 now
so 3 2 hours and a half so three hours
three hours about three hours you ready
to go get something to eat tomorrow yeah
I would like well we
tomorrow we're going to get something
eat tomorrow we'll either do you want to
do tai or you want to do Mexican I don't
know we'll see how what mood I'm in
tomorrow because I don't I don't really
know it'll be either one we got to do
the [__] mail though I got all right
you got to drop off the [__] um I
know you got returns return I said that
you got to do and then Saturday yeah we
I have to go to my stepdad's I'll take
you there funeral yeah yeah at noon
we'll go so okay Jenna shut it down yeah
we can shut it down um so yeah so thank
you very much to Kips uh [__] for
sending us the books like I said I had
never heard of this case and this [__]
was like [__] fascinating I I think I
read that book like in I read it in two
like big chunks I read like half of it
like just and then I read the other half
of it like before the show and I was
just like this is [__] crazy she in
her dressing room reading it yeah I well
she's on the floor with the cat well the
is good in there yeah he came in and
laughed at me cuz I was sitting on the
floor like by the window cuz the light's
not great in here it's kind of too dark
for me to read cuz I can't see all that
good so I would go in my dressing room
next door cuz there's a real big window
and it's bright so I was sitting there
by the window and like Bambi came in and
like just curled up like next to me so
I'm sitting there like on the floor like
with Bambi like like when I'm reading
the book and stuff Tom's like what the
[__] are you doing sitting on the floor
and I'm just like I can't see in my
office but yeah so but it was a really
good both of the books were really good
but that one was like [__]
fascinating and I can't believe that I
never heard of this case cuz this shit's
insane yeah too she she outlived
everyone yeah she's still as far as I
know she's still alive I couldn't find
her obituary I found her sister's
obituary Jennifer but I didn't find her
so as far as I know she's still alive
she's out she's not in prison anymore
Justice was not served she got out in
2004 and then she was on probation for
several years too seemingly Justice was
not served as far as we know no like I
said I think she killed a lot more
people instead of lot more fires than
she got uh convicted for so and she only
ended up serving 10 years in prison for
all of the [__] that he did which she
did which is insane um but yeah so we're
going to wrap it up I might stream
tomorrow because I do have a movie
review prepared uh it's actually for the
20 2022 2023 movie called Brooklyn 45
which is on um shudder so if you want to
watch that I might talk about it
tomorrow uh it's actually good it's set
during like right after World War II and
it's like a seance type movie yeah um
and I quite liked it so you know based
on what we said
today we really ought to work out some
kind of a May West show maybe you should
put that in in in yeah let me write that
under here yeah put that put that in the
running and they'll vote on it but I
would love to do a show on May West I
would too actually may West was [__]
uh she was quite a player and way ahead
of her time and there was a lot of funny
[__] and on YouTube there's a lot of
[__] cool clips of May West saying
some [__] back in the 30s all right that
you can relate to you're like yeah yeah
that's the way it really is because she
was a
realist especially when it came to sex
yeah yeah she's just a good character I
kind of feel like if you transported her
to modern times she would probably fit
right in oh yeah she'd love it and we
could like hang out she'd love it today
she she' be on only fans oh big time
yeah she like I said she would fit right
in she's just like oh okay we have this
now all right and um I can do that as
being being in the fitness scene and
being kind of a a bodybuilder myself
[__] West introduced uh [__]
bronze era or maybe silver era
bodybuilding to the masses because she
liked muscle she liked raw man muscle
she didn't care what race it was as long
as you looked good she'd go out with you
and that was a lot of her [__] stick
later on is to have muscle men around
her they probably wouldn't be musle men
compared by today's standards but uh she
lik dudes that were shirtless and she'd
tell jokes and [__] go yeah that's
all beef there you know well she was
just kind of like getting back cuz you
know there's been a long thing of like
dudes with like all these hot women like
she's like man I'm going to do that she
flipped it around she was bringing
female sexuality to the mainstream of
like and everybody's like oh yeah yeah
we like meat too you know what I mean
and that was that was her game yeah yeah
quite in the same way but I don't
similar it's not that different no not
that
different positive sexism you know she
was saying what she liked yeah yeah
which is that that's cool that's a
woman's prerogative sure yeah that's
what I mean yeah we should do a show
about her I'll put it I'll put it in she
was a great character yeah the poll's
going up Friday morning if you're as
always if you're because I am doing a
poll this week I didn't do one this week
because we were doing this topic because
I wanted to but um yeah poll goes up
Friday at 10 a.m. eastern time on
patreon and on YouTube so if you're a
YouTube member or you're on our patreon
then you can vote into poll as always so
that will go up Friday morning and I
will put an the anthrax thing and may
West in the poll yeah among other things
so we'll see what wins all right so as I
said I might do a movie review tomorrow
probably in the afternoon we'll see how
it goes because I do have one kind of
ready to go and I guess that will do it
for the show like I said Thank you again
mut to/ tops for sending us the books I
really did like them and I didn't know
anything about this case and this was
crazy as [__] so hopefully you guys
enjoyed it as much as we enjoyed talking
about it and we will see you guys again
both of us will see you again on Friday
night